I'll start streamin let's see if good
old YouTube oh yes all right cool make
sure that literally what I want to grab
my mouth welcome to the I lost podcast
and the Lords of gaming dotnet episode
number 134 and King is using these
emojis a dozen another glorious Sunday
Wow so I can't even finish today salut
bro Oh loop of joining the realm dead
right during the intro I had to give
that up to you bro much love for joining
the realm becoming a full subscriber to
the channel so it's another glorious
Sunday we're back at the roundtable on
the Lord's Day
we've got pokemon soul shield
impressions Jedi fall in order isn't
Google stadia do 8 mm mm x owed 19
reactions to discuss so we gonna get
right into it marks boy what's up
brother happy birthday to you already
know Scorpio season so let's introduce
the Four Horsemen of gaming those
Knights of the realm at the roundtable
my brother from another mother the
difficult game and the how are you doing
I'm doing pretty good playing Pokemon
and in this and of course we have I will
tell you who came along the so don't
play that list for the second play
experience and also the softer darkness
mister author low profile Illuminati
himself Bobby sovereign are you good
morning
I've got frauding all week barely in any
gaming one our Pokemon but I have under
my belt to the week that's it
no ball in order which is ego force of
it I've seen these aboard
I'll see you field domination mode here
Oh deaf sig is out here with the frontal
all man it's gonna be less out
double-barrel gaming my brother moon
snick excel was going on bro no doubt
soft and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the XS game
experience it
ooh be love it let's give a round of
applause everybody the room stand up and
salute that man woo that man that man in
that red that man what I did I went to
fairway and first of all I gotta cut out
to Ryu BAE all right and he was the
first person I saw cuz I put it up me
Midori and I was watching cheese being
made on YouTube so I go to the fairway
and they have a whole cheese section get
their cheese that I saw all right
and they had a look
because you know they had a big one I
had a little what I'm like okay I'm
gonna get there I tried it so the dew
was telling me yo you got to get
crackers and this is some sour stuff
that you got to put like it's a puree or
something like that let me get a cherry
sour look at the crack is you know look
like the body of Christ crackers I pick
my pick my cheese right so this is the
funniest joke driving my car down put on
fresh air freshmen they're back all
right so get aside when I went to get
some office I take out the keys I lay
out the crackers that's what I threw up
the picture so shout out to Ryu babe
he's the first person I saw that told me
exactly what the cheese was stuff like
these ones I just want to put it out to
for your own doubt to spread my
fantastic glorious we had a new member -
oh shut up and so many people shout out
to Miss boomstick shoutout was it
Delilah HD I believe it was so many
people and I don't I don't want to miss
y'all but Ryan raised the first dude
that put that up meet him at a little
dialogue going through and I love his
story so much because he told me that he
grew up so poor when he was young that
now that because he grew up in the Bronx
and he'd been into Mount Vernon and he's
wandering around the same circles that
you know we were in and he said now that
he's a little more financially stable
now he's a little has a little bit more
equity in his pocket he goes and he
tries the stuff that he never way were
to try as youth and I was like it
resonated so much with me that I
connected with him so much on on Twitter
yesterday that I had to give a shout out
I had to talk about that and it was all
over cheese y'all
the fact that I can connect over cheese
with somebody y'all guys got to stop
with this stuff on Twitter man were I
see you guys out there Cap'n and it's
very good to you know support you joint
I'm not I'm not trying to flame you
dudes for support what you like because
I saw something for the rock put up and
I told him because peoples going that
Porter rocks head and I said there's
nothing wrong with him liking what he
likes
mm-hm but you can't force I don't like
chocolate ice cream so you're not gonna
force me facts so if he doesn't support
what you support wholeheartedly that men
have a right to his opinion and you can
start turning nasty with your words
towards each other and we're all
together we all in the same joint
together facts all right baby
I see Christopher Hart having to defend
his self because of something that he
likes and you know what yeah everybody
could sit there oh you know King Leo you
shot now Christopher Hart hmm I'm not a
fraud
I got a PlayStation 2 mmm i play on
playstation i play on switch i play on
all these things what some members of
the community need to do is allow
everyone to know it stop capping for one
side but you did you won't do it right
if you can cap press I know you got an
Xbox to know what you really do know
though right so that you not misleading
cuz there's a lot of dudes a lot of a
lot of kids don't take the time out the
fact check yo pay that is sure to go
through and figure out who you are and
know that you aim everywhere these dudes
don't understand that me out here waving
a flag for you but in the secret you
know next box oh you're all got a
gamepad to all right and sometimes they
did financially struggling and if you
gave the dude the word your brother died
you gave him the word young man go play
that game pass mmm
you might be breaking down a wall that
we
[Laughter]
comes out here man I've seen a lot of
skill Dominus some of the Johan cell
just joined a bronze tier to realm out
here my brother you know said boom we
already said it got Christopher Hart
everybody up idiot
Galloway it's looking real it be I'm
like what I'm seeing out here and of
course your ego with the gold oh oh
really man that's a little I'm seeing
these Phil Dominus is out here no they
got the filled oxo we gonna get back so
we go get the eggs so if illegals like
yo game passing X cloudberry steady oh
shut the brat to dollar super chair I
gotta get Kojima his breath
[Music]
gaming ninja himself this shouldn't all
be on his post warned a celebration
friggin that realness to the ramen IOP
not telling you what you want to hear
but what you need to hear oh so do OB de
da de ja it was a subscribe oh wow I'm
glad you subscribe down that's what's up
man but yet man you already know
everything is good fresh off that
birthday I had a little fun you know I'm
saying overdid it a little bit of shot
to look about supposed to hit scub cast
I'm like look I'm looking real spooky I
did catch you on Friday okay this is
what happened then I fall asleep
listening to everybody's podcast like I
put it in I'm gonna put in that work I'm
listening to yo guys maybe if I don't
catch y'all fresh I'm definitely gonna
listen to y'all later
I gotta give a shout-out to three dudes
I got to give us a shout out to R and
outdoor the cold East would never get a
shout-out to deal not in that order to
deal anyway but dude that kept me a
breath on a soul now with you guys
because I needed to beat it but I had to
pick a kid we addressing in a building
kiss mo fellas
we had the nice I had a good a good job
I had a good a good job we had some real
fun live reactions chat was laughing you
know
oh yeah shout out to New York and whitey
music with the finalists super chat say
something brother technically a super
super sticker that's what they're okay
super sticker good your local middle you
know we have some Lords in the realm
that's on the healing right now yeah
need to give a shout out to Lord J barn
right now he's healing he's in the
hospital he's getting better
um shout out to Lord dizzy these people
and shout out to Lord clowns oh yes sir
yes sir you know and anybody else in the
room you know y'all be child we're gonna
shout shout out like that and give you
that yeah all these laws man please send
him some love you know everybody's
healing up on the man man and like I
said we really appreciate if you guys
support them as we all our game and
brothers we always gotta check in on
each other so good point King yeah man
for me same old thing you know what I
got a chance to grind a little bit
little destiny obviously little X cloud
a little bit on Jedi fall in order we'll
get to that you know I'm saying and um
yeah watch me you into the backlog I
threw it on this is the police - YP
studios I was having fun with that cuz
my exercise there was no internet on the
plane had to come out dear but um yeah
as you already know you'll get it sees
announced for the show real quick so as
you already know as King put out a very
eloquent video please check that out of
the IOP YouTube channel the Lord's ever
joined the round man we've got some
subscription options some some things
for you a lot of you guys are already
joining I'm seeing fraud alerts right
now I've see it you know all these cool
things so again we have the tears can
you wanna break it down we got the three
tiers we got the bronze the silver
law and Lord gold so be a lord of
whatever you want to support you can
handle and then we got different pricing
structures we also have besides the
custom badges or the emojis yo the
bushes in Jeff's tickets going crazy but
um yeah again these are really cool shoe
I got graphic card
really did a fantastic job hook these
things up man looking really really cool
and yeah we also have some cool perks
for you guys exclusive content when we
go to the events coming boy we got more
this is just the beginning and it's
gonna be fun man but we got no more
people we get on the more funner all IOP
catchphrases we're gonna try to have
more of them in there this stuff we
sitting on but we want to just grow this
thing a little bit so uh salute
everybody who already show some support
we will get into the poll last week's
poll this was addicts bowl with mo
studios they have been announced to be
present Axl 19 which do you think will
deliver the most hype to the fanbase the
winner of the 4-way tie right now was an
obsidian watch your mouth watch of this
Lord kognito is in his feelings Paul is
ninja theory at 49% coming in that
second second place who should have been
the true king with obsidian and coming
in that third place and only 8% was
y'all better respect Microsoft's name I
mean Mike minecraft name in that last
place with a surprising 5% Wow
disrespecting in exile wow that's crazy
anyway o saw salute to sleepy God
willing to D well booted Lord bronze of
the round telling me to say nothing
dizzy all right I'm just giving your
poll answer don't you gotta be extra
shout out the deathsinger being the
first verses they throw a dick in the
bushes so Lord addict that at the the
dust has settled from excelencia we did
the little cool thing but now with the
poll what do you think man the people
were more excited about ninja Terry
coming in do you think they had that man
no I think everyone I think if anyone
got more height it was respawned
responded more to the actual than anyone
else
they're they're long that's crazy man
that's crazy but we got new poll coming
in at the end of the show so we gonna
get into these topics Lord added ma'am
gonna set it off with you actually gonna
add it because actually sloths off-topic
Oh pokey bar dropped so I get I get to
frauded listen to y'all stay true to my
word
did I many a month ago I said I'm gonna
get pulled yeah you didn't want to
repeat a let's go that's what's going on
let's go buy this pokeball and you could
throw it in oh thank you I got the
fuller today let's go so this is my
first ever Pokemon never ever I've never
touched one I know it's little Cognito
fraud a member just bend the knees with
a talk about the power
you should be able to survive continue
kid my first paid and I have to say I
somebody who's never played I it's good
because I'm looking at it from a very
objective point of view just as an RPG
right I don't I'm not looking at it like
oh it's missing this it's missing that
so we have attics for that which is
great um but for me immediately from the
bat right you have this it's super
Japanese RPG so you have those Japanese
sort of like tendencies in terms of the
characters and the way they look those
those humongous dead eyes that they have
like that painterly sort of like heart
look to it the game looks pretty it's
but it's very much it looks like a like
an old game of res you know when you
look at the things that are cool about
in terms of tech that I would say like I
was surprised like when you go into
buildings they load pretty quickly the
draw distance when you're outside in the
world you can literally see like down
doesn't that top-down
no it's not top-down it's sort of it's
sort of like more of a three-quarter
almost behind the back it gives you like
a little bit of distance you'll see it's
a it's a weird angle it's not behind all
right it's a little elevated and it's
not definitely not top down yeah my my
son is definitely gonna get um see I'm
torn right now with the switch
oh the switch stand still oh the Xbox
one you know I'm still torn for him
right now so yeah I get him the one kid
who the one forget if he's a big Pokemon
friend definitely like but not yeah so I
always do this and Lord chunk later yes
I give it so far a three and a half out
of five chocolate can't be given any
chocolate wait an hour
I said an addict gets his hands on this
game in the short amount of time he's
has it he's gonna play more than me
which is of course that's exactly what
happened anyway
so what I will say is the intro of the
game was hilarious because you have this
Pokemon master and the champion of the
of the Gaylor region that you have to
say that name again what
our game our NATO it's it's the gale our
reason to me I'm mispronouncing it oh
well sorry I don't know it might be like
I feel like it's not voice acted which
in this day and age is kind of a shame
but you know that's another thing so he
comes down this dudes like this Elvis
character with a cape he's really full
of himself it is hilarious but he's man
useful but he is very useful yes so I'm
hope all's and stuff I'll be loving that
dude and I'll be like I'll come through
any time you want jump I will say this
it feels like this is a reboot for them
they know they're trying to bring a new
player just in the very beginning it's
they explain basic things about Pokemon
in a way they know they're getting new
players in the beginning yes yes
absolutely I don't know if they do that
[Laughter]
what is it it feels like a very cool
like RPG I get why people love this I
get how people get so attached to
Pokemon I get like when you get into the
minutiae of the one-on-one combat and
figuring out what powers do do what
against certain pokemon what's strong
what is it strong that part is very cool
the only thing from at knowing that this
series has been around so long I'm so
disappointed with how like when you
at the combat that combat looks kind of
exactly how I remember seeing a gameboy
like in perspective and everything to
combat yeah just wait a Playboy watching
I don't know look look look not gameplay
look if you would have said something
like pokemon stadium Oh blah right man
you aren't ooh something there look at
something like pokken tournament this is
what I'm talking about it let go
somebody who has somebody who has
history with this wait with the game and
I don't I'm just looking at it
objectively from the outside I see it
and I'm like okay I picked I picked the
score bunny the the fire bunny as my my
starter right so immediately he gets me
he has a move called embrace at first
like special move you get is just him a
fire like attack but the animations wood
is super simple it's like okay I
improved that's for sure you look at
something like pokken tournament right
it is a fighting game right but when you
look at the interactions yeah you're
telling me you couldn't you couldn't
animate them differently so the fights
feel more sort of like so sovereign it
doesn't look as good as Pokemon
tournament on GameCube I mean
interesting pokken tournament poker
tournament whatever you wanna call it I
call it pokey because a pokemons fine
but okay in terms of how they animated
interact with one another no and I'm
like okay I understand it's a turn-based
RPG but when you look at you could
animate them better like it's the funny
part is the reason supposedly there's no
national dex in there or anything is
because they were supposed to update all
these animations but they did so it's
like you have a bunch of new Pokemon
they're not adding the old ones but then
when you look at what they've done it
still still that's what I say it feels
like and again I could be wrong about
that but I'm remembering playing
watching car BOTS who play on game
whatever it just seems like the
perspective is the same way obviously
the animations are better than that
but in general how the game plays that
hasn't changed pretty much at all and
it's disappointing like you have a move
called tackle right so I'm like right in
a 20-19 game show my Pokemon trying to
tackle the other words and then you just
see you eat right so we hit the tackle
is literally a kick to the face to the
face they barely react to done so much
more with this it sort of feels like
that it feels super safe in that regard
I'm like ah man like you know after all
this me never wanting to touch this
series and to get into it now I'm like
okay it's the feels just like kind of
what I expected it to be and nothing
more it's not really surprising me right
but again I like the fact that I'm
coming at it from a brand new
perspective really know what it is so in
terms of the RPG mechanics it feels like
something I would like cuz I want to see
how the Pokemon involve I want to see
how these moves affect all the pokemon
that's cool just the way it looks like
it feels lazy and I hate using that
description but it feels lazy and ever
you know real quick before you finish I
just wanted to ask his arm there's a lot
of debate going on right now because
shop Lord gave me nets
Oh Daniel May aka God knows Kondo he's
got a great article right now look
that's gonna read yeah he's got a great
article on Pokemon and it looks like
this like I don't say like a civil war
but there's some controversy saw and
they're seeing about the the Pokedex and
certain Pokemon immiscible war there's
people that's right people that's wrong
what's going on what it is people think
you given its endo too many passes right
like whole game free to the fire they
need to improve the franchise they need
to stop doing the bare
you know I was hard on this game I was
like I don't know about this [ __ ] you
don't you don't be talking about about
um I was not watching last week's
podcast last night after I got home and
then when you said I'm gonna pick up
Luigi's Mansion on Black Friday I
definitely want that game I thought you
know cuz I like Luigi's Mansion and I
thought it was like one of the shining
points in the Gamecube so they are
learning how to ride a bike again what
does that have to do first off chief the
switch is a hybrid I'm going by what the
actual company promotes their brand I
think the I think the company knows
their brand better than you do
second off this is the first Pokemon to
be on console in a very long time it's a
you know we're not even talking about
the Pokemon stadiums and the Pokemon
Coliseum's and they had that weird one
for the Wii and they had that one where
you still Pokemon on the Gamecube we're
not talking about them we're talking
about a full-blown Pokemon game why is
it look like the 3ds version Oh
step it Wow yo I heard Digital finals
were going in man had a good section
they were talking about see that's not
gonna stop me playing I'm still playing
but that make no mistake like the
overstay we got two superb Rabi sick
give addict that light cave diving look
like added abilities to loot the iron
Lords panel much love brother really
appreciate if y'all see us using easy mo
do you like this right here like how we
throwing attic in the bushes if y'all
see that
oh speaking of which right on top shout
out to your hotel
he said attic I like you but you trade
in Luigi's Mansion in the bushes emoji
you don't want to get those I mean cuz
we have over a hundred people watching
right now you see with the joint Bert
button is subscribe hit that also hit
the notification button so you guys can
definitely have all of you you guys are
always making fun of me King you can
officially put us in the bush do that
subscription Bush's the Boise or he said
it's the switch version with gimped no
passion I don't like to be honest with
you one of the biggest because I didn't
want to solve with this 40 minutes
experience I have an objective we gotta
take bills right this is crazy Oh shadow
and to my team music one of our first
Lord gold got second Lord Gold's of a
subscription service Wow
thank you brother really appreciate it
and they saw shout out to gamer by
choice welcome to the bronze round for
both you right now I'm gonna need that
I'm gonna need that into the bushes in
that emo chat right now yes for adding I
didn't attend trade into his mansion so
why bring up old stuff yo chief Tommy
coming at y'all again he said three TS
in plain English it is when he didn't
pick up let's go Pikachu he claimed he
was going to pick up the remember
there's no time frauding there's no
doubt but we all go I wasn't paying
those $60 for that half big version if
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do this one
right that other one with some like
introduction and I want to make sure my
pocket watch
Digital boundary making LOCOG me go
[Music]
Lokar dinos a frog but you know I'm the
bush i before off without picking up you
in the bushes betrayed little we just
made you for it music said graphic god
nice work on knees well yes please
salute the graphic god he's in our
ground right now please leo fantastic
job I'm telling you now as you're see
more members is growing inside right yup
I see more emojis pop up and next week
when your comeback so Lord other
distinct said we are done with this it's
a Pokemon game they need to increase the
production value of these Pokemon games
I do I will say just from playing a
little bit of it it seems like you know
there's a lot more effort going into an
area to focus but no voice to the to
downloads to moving on
thank you Lord others eat we will be
getting into shout out to the geeky die
writing topics long so it could have
beat side effects
ready ready for the neck so but oh yeah
but we got to get into a mess Star Wars
or fallen order it dropped
lot to discuss so um Lord added you want
to set this off man I believe everybody
picked it up I drove King y'all good
chance you picked a we could did we get
this so what if I can change it live
though and put it in don't bring over
you my lord addict been Star Wars is out
I know you mean we talked offline said
about what 10 15 hours something like
that you got in what are your
impressions how you feel it right now I
absolutely love this game shout out to
respawn for giving me something great no
I need all right like it's always nice
you know to give with the the white 5
weapons that always use in Dark Souls
games and actually in blood-borne I only
used one but there's something special
with taking a lightsaber to someone's
noggin in a dark suit issue with is for
some reason like obviously they wanted
they didn't want to raid it in but when
I use when I go across someone's adamant
with the lightsaber I expect him to not
have that again so some killing
animations so it's like inconsistent
sometimes you'll you'll cut like a
monster's head off but you won't cut
like stormtroopers in half they're not
doing that that's what I expect with the
lights Avery it's nothing like nothing
to go at it over but I expect a
lightsaber that's you know the
temperature of the Sun Brooking by
Disney let's cut that oh yeah oh yeah
you write this New York shout to Disney
Disney enforcement yeah I still enjoy it
it's got it's one of the very few games
where the actual map is useful mm-hmm
I really enjoy the fact that they found
a good middle Brian I feel like with
this game the Dark Souls format
population is gonna get bigger because
there's a lot of people like myself when
I bought it why they buy the shout out
to kiss me
it's a lot of people like myself that
didn't even know this game was a Dark
Souls game I kind of thought it would be
a little bit more towards the Unleashed
error mm-hmm but when I got on here is
that I'm sitting first thing I noticed
is there there's the rest thing it says
enemy spawn it's loading click with me
when it really traumatic is did the
force fix Forest Whitaker's I couldn't
fix it so I wanna know know what I
noticed what happened and they literally
jacked the Dark Souls formula is what I
was when I died for the first time
mm-hmm it said my XP was put on to that
dude I'm like it just hit well I started
seeing everything I was like they have
the spawning stuff they have the
shortcut stuff from the Dark Souls
series they have the you know when you
die the person who's like yo this is for
me to be buying for that game between
all
[Music]
[Applause]
lords were not Kings Lords Kings y'all
not trying to say your name would you
hold love it I don't know as a person
that has beaten shik row star wars is
amazing it is star checkers stole my
game of the year yes pray dose it's it's
it's not gears finally up to a Jedi
fallen order did you cop sword it was
it's nothing not not on your radar uh
it's on my radar but I did say I was
gonna wait for the reviews for this game
because I was just on edge you know II a
man use on that des training thing now I
gotta run around the streets moving that
dope when you play dead straining you
know did you
they how much how much did you move how
much did you carry from one point to the
end did it make you what's worth it did
it exhaust you because that's what I
hear it does they did exhaust you Amy
this Rena is a whole nother shebang made
[Music]
everyone who bought this game and played
it they realize especially was yeah I
would say up there with a game of the
generation most definitely be game of
the year without a doubt
only at 29 C would this game be a game
of the year because I'm seeing all of
these top tier games they're all making
it with their training when it comes to
review reception oh yes one saying
there's not really a breakout game that
jima got that that buff man he got that
curve hey you know where you get that
win you spent 30 years making 90 plus
rated games so we are maybe that he got
a curve got names on the game and his
legacy precedes him of course people are
gonna be more fun to that this game is
he raised the cells of drugs to play
this game no no listen let me ask you a
question because um I didn't purchase
the game I'm not purchasing the game as
you can see from my ranch on Twitter
somebody's gonna buy me that game you
can feel great and purchasing the game
for the king and I will play nobody in
hell I'm giving them a nickel defaming
Americans in that whole aspect of it so
I'm not better than either a man at all
but then that's my personal opinion it
has nothing to do with anybody on this
path you riding a big payday correct
they do the trick no they didn't correct
it sir he means to correct that somebody
was corrected that he left that he let
it sit just like that so he didn't feel
like he don't in this face it's just a
great valid point yeah that's a great
valid point you know anybody went over
that way I am no in no position to tell
them not to again I could care less
about Kojima but you cannot deny his
previous great my question is this fee
right if his name wasn't on the box yeah
right take his name off that box is that
something that you're running on
purchased now
mind you there would be no hype if
there's no name attached to this box
with Ujima because I believe that the
most hype with this game was because it
was Chema's name attached to it now the
game looks beautiful it looks beautiful
but if his name is not attached on the
box is it a first-day purchase for you
is are you yelling out game of the year
or what's going on with you with the
game if he's not associated with it at
all
okay if kojima name was associated with
this game it would have not had the
publicity that it has that's what I
don't know no no lie his his name again
his legacy his legacy precedes him again
he's a rock or in gaming he's been like
that here's something right not to take
away from the game we do have several
rock stars in this gaming community in
the image in a gaming industry we know
that but I think and it's all fair the
mere fact that he's such a big name that
people will discredit the game or take
some away from the game and that's fine
I'm all for that
now if his name wasn't associated with
this game will my attention would have
been grabbed if Sony wouldn't market
this game and if they wish you know the
same marketing everything for this game
showing the trailers how they showed it
and no nobody will probably have did
that because this would have went on
that okay you know because yeah it would
have been on a second-tier level right
but with the scores being at the end of
the day I do believe this would have
remained the same I'm gonna tell you why
once you boot this game up you see that
it's special once you put some time into
it you see once this game starts opening
up then you find out people are mind
blown because it's game B these are my
most die-hard Xbox brethren I don't
women's for the streets in YouTube
streets I saw them have said listen I
crapped on this game this was not on my
radar I have to take the low phony I
have to take that looking good today no
I can't put it down and it's a very
divisive game it really is is a very
divisive game because
with their I will put it on the lever as
VR right mm-hmm
if you have a VR and you own a VR you
will say hey this is great I love it
right but yeah how do you market VR to
somebody who can't see it with their
eyes so you can't tell uh you can't
experience the VR experience unless you
put that helmet on you know what I know
Jay he won't know how much time you put
in the game he's curious uh I would say
I would say a couple hours you'll start
seeing what it is but man once you get
to that five six hour mark that's when
you listen I'm gonna tell you one scene
that they grab me and it's not a spoiler
but I was walking up a cliff I had about
the game your delivery you have you have
these packages right in enough mommy
made it these packages which are the bad
spirits or whatever and I made it to
this big huge crater it is overlooking
the whole scenery stuff in the music
exam you know I tell you just that
scenery and then with their music it
does something to you man it hits you
this drug start to catch me though this
guy is a genius and I'm not the only one
it says that right uncle we know the
reviews you can read just all your
friends who play xbox - he actually kind
of shares some sentiments that you said
listen I can't take anybody who's
enjoying it clearly it's a divisive
games not for a lot of the Lords here
but the man a mulligan on this one for
anybody that thought it was anything I
definitely get a mulligan on this
because I felt that this was his breakup
song and this was you know fresh off a
breakup he put this out so if anybody
didn't think the numbers was up to snuff
I honestly truly I will stake my knees
on the necklace it being a 10 she taught
me the problem is that I have with this
there's the cause for some reason of the
pros for this game like
with seating right again here you have
to play it
this game is so divisive because from
the outside even myself looking at it
from the outside
why is kijima only showing you walking
delivering packages why everything he's
showing is like this is trash is just a
bunch of movie trailers so when he went
solo movie trailer is he gonna spoil the
movie game for you once once you once
you get once you actually played the
game you see it for yourself
you realize it's less about being FedEx
is less about that it's more about
everything else before you open up you
know talking about death boring then
shout out to your house Elvia has the
topic is about star wars kid goes DS
let's back on some so Jacob I just got a
sheet row I was leading you didn't copy
played there shame we got that part
my question to you now is Star Wars
something you're interested in picking
up yes yeah again I said I was gonna
wait for the reviews to come out yes
came out and it's it's it's good it's
looking good I'm gonna cop it I'll
probably copy right after the [ __ ] no
doubt no doubt King we already know
where you're at let me jump in right
quick listen look I mean obviously yaar
you know I'm a huge fan of respawn I
think least more honestly have not made
you might be their biggest fan I am
probably one of their biggest fan next a
bunch of my grease board is up there for
me you don't say it but um yo doing or
completely
super cinematic feel like it's like to
me uncharted
Dark Souls a little titanfall with the
wall running stuff but it's like they
had a baby man this thing is high
production value like ridiculous you
know I'm saying so the set piece is a
fire I came from the platforming
elements jumping from you know that's
where your char today's like the way you
you know how you hold on a chart and you
do it a little down to the side you come
down like everything about it is just
really really really fired the abilities
the force pushing pillow - stuff is
crate and then you got the lightsaber
action like I'm not a Star Wars fan boy
like that but this feels like a
straight-up
you're playing a game movie like this
feels like yo this is its own thing and
it's really really dumb well I think
that the voice acting is top-notch they
like yo they got with a shout out to
respawn because at the end of the day
I'm not using frostbite I love the fact
that they're so dominate over there EA
can't even like EA can even book like
normally a says you'll get in line
everybody's doing you frostbite and
they're like no fam we're doing unreal
now I gotta be room there are some
issues that the technical stuff oh you
know I'm running I was playing on the X
you know I notice a little bit of like a
saint shutter stop let me know if you
experience this or anybody's got it like
when you stand still you kind of rotate
the camera around I don't notice it a
little slight stuff I will say I'm not
playing in performance mode cuz shot to
a digital foundry performance boy it
never really hit 60 and it said it's a
little bit of pacing but it is really a
beautiful game like the HDR to go on
from the one planet that's really lit up
with the vegetation and the water
you said performance more what do you
mean so they have no choice you got the
performance mode or you got the I guess
the fidelity mode I left it on the stand
infidel emo waster 1440p and then I
believe the UM - what you call a de the
other more things 1080p max but you know
you it's trying to go above 30 and I'm
saying okay yeah so I mean it's it's
really is really good I mean they they
got one did like you could already tell
just by playing the first two three
hours this got game of the Year feel
like okay off rip like I'm like oh we
were
at e3 and we got you know the private
screening with it and we saw it again we
didn't get a chance to touch the game we
got a chance to see the game and I
thought the game looked phenomenal for
what I saw right um I just have a lot of
you know caveats when it comes to
purchasing games at this moment you know
that's my but I want to say one thing
I'm shout out to anchorman new Lord in
the realm he's in the chat yes yes
anchorman I was thinking maybe me and
you need to do a Mandalorian episode
recap once a week if you have Disney
Plus yeah and we can definitely do a
deep dive into every episode once a week
probably like on a Monday or something
like that we can give these fans stuff
and everybody that joins us can they
have early access to those episodes
unify fire because I'm deep deep in Star
Wars our law and this man that took man
Laurie is ridiculous yeah you just said
it cuz like now I want to watch like I'm
I'm not a Star Wars fan boy I really I
come at a good tweet to drop anyway
because he's the same boat as me
we are not stamp Star Wars fan boys at
all I don't hate the series but I'm not
like oh my god came out I'm a similar
thing like I became a little more of a
fan of it after the Couture series but
like but you know Disney's been fairy
Perry but we in about that dark life we
don't know about moonshine rainbows I'm
a Star Wars junkie and a Disney Plus
that service if you go into it you see
that delay all the movies out and you
can watch them in any order one movie
they don't have is the Han Solo I
understand attic what's up with that
that's not there but all other movies is
there and they give you like yesterday I
was on my phone I was you know some
downtime I was watching a first one all
over again the Phantom Menace because
you know Darth Maul was my dude I was
watching that and I saw that Star Wars
and trust me it's taking everything in
me not to go and purchase it and
we're getting to that egg some topics I
will tell you exactly why mother
purchasing anything anymore good let me
pay the bills remix Cedric h2 father
super chat thank you brother brat with
the file I love super chat that's
trending is not for everyone
I'll say this it's a game that evokes a
lot of emotion and curiosity it's
surprisingly addicting and last one from
Bratz which was console version of Jedi
fallen order does this game no justice
on PC the higher textures powerful
protocol effects lighting just wow yeah
I gotta admit man I mean I'm hearing
great things with the PC the only reason
why I did the the ex was cuz Lee I want
to do to God the console streaming and
the the achievements all that stuff but
what you said so I heard you chirp
enough of that HDR yeah so I'm like let
me do that plus with X cloud I can
continue my joint at work with the
console generally want to test it out on
that cloud later on you don't have it
it's touch and go like a lot of PC games
don't have HDR because their access to
HDR is not adding what about the powers
don't wear you out with it just real
quick
what I what I like that response thought
is that that's been issues in previous
Star Wars games that you know not been
the first person shooter battlefront
games is they've always had out like
throw massive amounts of enemies at you
so sometimes it felt like real
inconsistent like stone troopers sure
always go down on one hit with a
lightsaber it should never be anything
else but on here they're like you know
we'll give you that but we're not gonna
throw massive amounts of enemies at you
we're gonna put well targeted enemies
that that would make your life hell so
you know they put that in there is it
just if those real balance it doesn't
feel like you know you're doing nothing
but making an action game like like
unleashed if it was like when you do
have those lightsaber battle it's like
if those more personal that's what I was
about to say because I was asked why I
want to ask you because I want to spoil
4p that in play but you get to like the
end of the first act and there's a
conference yeah go tell me like you knew
at me
you I think we both share that we love
epic boss fights right like they got to
feel any real time to cinematic like the
first time when she walked up and she
jumped down shatter or a lifesaver
the first thing I say is like she bought
the what my I was like yo dis again they
they just have that feel that epic
confrontation and then you got a couple
of QuickTime stuff going on but then you
got back to the fighting then you got
your parent everything has to be on
point obviously we know during that
section for story reasons how it was
gonna go but yo if the gate what I'm
saying is I'm early but if the game
continues like this mm-hmm
this this is this is this got that game
of the year field three so i if you guys
haven't seen our reaction said it we
said it at EA play was like this looks
like a game with the Year contender we
neva know what the game was at that
point it just looked like a straight
action game and it was no talk of it
being like a Metroidvania it's always
like and what we saw was so impressive
just to I'm so happy for respawn yeah so
happy that that EA finally realized look
we we're not gonna throw out another
game out there that it sees that being
it being a small games help helps that
that's not gonna have to say even if EA
turns around
it's cuz you have to you have respawn a
thing I mean I think Reese showing them
that like look you you don't have to
nickel and dime people to make a good
gas like no microtransactions no extra
stuff on the on the menu like it's just
straight single-player story let's go we
yeah that's not EA like normally a were
fight and let's be real it's not impacts
legends yeah and now this EA Loki take
this super trailer away so we got two
dollar super chat from a pixel bit G I'm
on my fourth world fallen order is my
game of the year well you know we got
150 people thank you everyone for coming
out definitely it that like but if you
guys don't mind it's always appreciated
now EA is that they have one Star Wars
game
under their belt if they were smart they
just wish they don't decide I feel like
if they don't hint that Star Wars out of
the park
yeah it might be a rap for them with
straw with the light they had
David is a rep for them anyway was told
unless they leave it and they hold off
and they let respawn make the last one
ago and it's a either sequel to this is
something I don't I don't think out of
1/3 I think they were bad critically and
they got bashed out a lot with the Star
Wars but battlefront still sold well I'm
truly upset for this they said they was
gonna have a trial inside all-access
talked about it and my stupid behind I
didn't totally forget I always forget
that I have EA access right until my
credit card is charged so the boy back
in again for one more year but you know
what
get that phone orders coming up I'm
gonna get my little yep why because my
behind was going blaze through but this
is the thing I don't give a damn I paid
30 something dollars for the year I
should be able to blaze what I've been
dropping all type of these crap titles I
don't care about your wrestling man your
2k or whatever hell that you put me me
yes you own is a game that I wanted to
play daddy well played it and then you
want to hold it back you wanna say no
timeout chilla I wish I can go in I bet
you if you looked at the terms and
service this is some charity protect him
yeah but I agree because bike shout the
car bomb so cuz I was like I was gonna
do the same thing with the Hazama Oh
usually about a week before
you get that 10 hour trial all right
wait wait I'm like the stupid racing is
in there put the stupid racing in there
you know gonna put the Jedi joint yo and
the Star Wars coming up next month
Disney just money for the game is PC if
you do the orders at the origin access
you know Phil from making them bending
me to throw them up inside X X was the
ultimate Xbox
shout out to him for making them put EA
for free for the $2 super chat this is a
sore you takin are you talking Jedi red
there too or outer worlds game of the
year right worlds Resident Evil 2 is
definitely not game of the year if you
want it was a great game but I I'm not
forgiving games outer worlds it was a
good game but a Jedi's better my game of
the year so Sakura so I got like a pole
anyway moving on because we got a lot of
show but oh yeah me I want to actually I
know we gonna hit EXO then we go hit it
but I just walk Mike J governability
though but I want to talk about one
aspect first and that is the whole
stadia situation and all yes so
obviously we build stadiums coming out
which is next week
lady in the bushes first and the later
we'll put the film
now steamers respawn is on a roll it
would be perfect deaths for Halo if they
weren't under he a I sure hope three
four three could they live a similar
gunplay with infinite you know what you
maybe you wanna stop shouting pushes to
the chat all the subs going crazy
shout to Brad to follow switch a shout
to feel forgiven us phantom dusk with
the original assets and four brutal
vents the baggage speaking of stadium
got K old by exile we gonna get into it
right now brat man we gonna get into it
man so look you know obviously shout out
to my boy Lord undead from Lords of
gaming that fantastic article right now
talking about everything going on with
stated he's asking this if it's a
glorified baby right now now I know
Kratos I know you disagree I know we
gonna get to you that's right your
supporters out there you annoyed bouche
but you know basically just want to go
over the issues right now obviously
November 19th is when it drops you know
there's been some some controversy you
know I'm saying obviously some of the
features um
people are saying they're not gonna be
available shout out to Paul TAS you got
the list of all the games you got
Assassin's Creed Odyssey destiny guilt
Just Dance 2020 kind Mortal Kombat 11
Red Dead Redemption to samurai shodown
and three to Redick a motion control
look at the screen are you gonna mimic
what you see will be able to tell which
oh yes they do prediction I just put a
little something in the chat little
15-day trial game pass ultimate so solve
out here I am right doing the Lord's
work better grab I grab quick so yeah we
got that that in the main thing right
now is a lot of features you know some
of the pre-orders date people a little
concerned that they wouldn't be you know
be met and then we have a lot of the
features that they had you know
announced at the um initially before the
AMA that are now you know yes but look
at me know there's only one game you can
play for free isn't this true Lord
Cognito I just want to know what's the
name of the game that you could play for
free the game if they made free to play
now you could play free on you got 12
games
do they come bundled indie get a chance
to you know like souls you booted up
[Music]
what about my TV my smart TV chromecast
doesn't work with the one that comes
with shout out to Phil Dominus certain
clone Phil over there
by a game of my choice lurking has been
rolling right now great show everyone
you know you're definitely you're not
onto something but you know so we have a
$2.00 super chair from none of your
business
not to yourself thanks for the
consistency thank you thank you very
much appreciate it so you deal
so obviously against a lot of the
features they say they're gonna clear
not gonna be available if they don't
have the achievement system ready
there's also what's available stream
connect family the whole thing with the
UM the buddy pass won't be ready till to
two weeks after and then I obviously the
iOS support which also in fairness
project as cloud does not have available
right now either
but what it brings back to the Lord's
obviously we saw XO 19 obviously we saw
what Project X clouds response was which
was 50 games immediately right now at
launch which definitely surpasses our
stadiums right they've also had talked
about because they they're gonna have PC
support and to Lord Chronos isn't a
surprise
supporting the controller thought about
you thought about you and he wanted to
get you in green into the ecosystem so
you me prepare my in the whole
PlayStation 4 man base here prepared
game past becomes the PlayStation
oh listen y'all heard it here okay not
hurt your leader
Kratos inside this chat let's get those
burning either he knows that they're
setting it up to get that Aurelius name
that Aurelius is gonna show up he
already started the a he already started
the a once once we included this into
the package they slipped it in Rachel
Joe
and just not like this go right y'all
controller works now pass no controller
works right now we're exit out so your
controller is already used to the good
premium so you gonna get used to the
good freedom now once you already in
don't you already used to playing with
it you just start demanding it you won't
start looking for it and it's no sure
right you're brand new are you said are
you saying that on that Microsoft's
planning a virus on Sony site here you
can use our controller they like to
control you with the gate person like
where is this sad it's okay it's on PC
and Xbox well I like this great value of
$9.99 for gaper so I'm gonna go get
where it is let me tell you something
right we know the end game yeah we do we
know see right now we know what
Microsoft is doing but this Maxim is
Spencer sir doesn't go with that because
we know we the face of the company we
don't know what's going on a lot of
other places they has a change in it you
know everything moving but this dude is
one consistent he's a consistent he's
inevitable it will be everywhere but you
see what happened to stadia right mmm
the bushes happened to them dudes they
went up against the boss the boss
smacked him down and he threw the fake
dude over there with the red clown shoes
he messed up the whole smoke remember he
was going if they would have
gave you the package with all of those
twelve games inside it would have made
some kind of sense right but then they
said they're going launch and none of
those features that they said the game
is dead and my only one that felt like
every time we heard something by stating
it was negative
things getting worse was it the fake
Phil oh now we got this controller
that's compatible with X cloud if that
is not monument that is monumental
because that is letting you know is
inclusion right is whatever controller
you have we want to make sure that
you're comfortable in your space of
gaming and that is any PlayStation dude
that can get a chance to use a
controller in X cloud you're gonna feel
comfortable with the games you're
playing that means that all that
vibrating controller stuff that Jay was
talking about with the PlayStation Fire
you'll be able to do that the Exile you
know all those special perks we want
y'all in with us man lord phil has
definitely stepped down off the mountain
with a xbox got bizarro feel happy so no
competition on this is true I want to
bring it back cuz I know we gonna get
into that whole Phil thing but I want to
focus on stadia right
so again with that announcement and what
all stuff that X cloud announced that X
oh right
is this cassava Kratos do you feel that
X cloud has base stadia do a let's start
with um do listen I think it's close
only one correct answer I'm just saying
maybe a bad talk please body is
eventually going to be there for Xbox on
forward that it's a great viable option
for anything you know options is always
good I'll never say table
will it make stadia do AI say no no I
know stadia is you know they market this
thing all wrong they're playing a long
game we're not coming in trying to tell
you tonight you know not trying to kick
you off your platform they're coming in
right the number one thing that we talk
about Microsoft is they have godly money
I mean there's another company out there
that has godly money and as Google
yes so you never count out a person that
has godly money because Google is
probably willing to spend even more more
so even what so money dedicated to
gaming day Microsoft so while yeah a lot
of the features that they advertised and
promised won't be there for the founders
which is lunch they're saying when they
roll it out to everybody else which is
in supposedly January yes these features
we want to be updated weekly games are
gonna be added weekly and again this is
them saying that not needed right um is
this ideal for them to come out with
with with all this stuff no right but
you know here's the thing the
PlayStation Xbox didn't come with any
other features that it has now back in
2013 when we launched it right and so I
look at this as a brand new platform and
I am willing me personally yeah I'm
willing to give them some time whether
it's six months or a year just see what
they can do and see if they come through
with what they need to come through with
to make this more marketable to me too
until then
it's out is it yes now is it for those
who are already near ecosystems I think
that's where it's just gonna stay let me
ask you this question for Pastor the
rest of laws in reference to you know
the thought process is two things going
on right now at least that I'm hearing
one there people feel that it's almost
like their tech like you said testing
the waters like this is almost it's
almost like a beta in some respect right
in a sense that you know that not all
the features available just yet again
everybody an ecosystem but the question
I had is and we're actually supposed to
talk about this on brat but we got off
topic which was about what the devs are
saying and there's this all develop I
believe for some puzzle game and didn't
yeah it's not getting one developer you
know saying we didn't talk about it but
you know their main thing was they were
like yo they concerned of stadium was
gonna be around and then they kind of
they kind of mentioned that they do feel
like they may be treating it like a soft
launch and and the whole thing about you
know the fact that Google sometimes has
a history with products that don't
succeed out the gate to kind of abandon
them so are you concerned in any way
long-term with them if they get out the
gate kind of rock no and I'm gonna tell
you because on the PlayStation side we
have PSVita
over a lot who cared about that Sony you
know supported that for X amount of
years and being a stay stopped they
stopped putting their developers on
there so I can't admonish the Google for
doing the same thing when all companies
have done that right hold on what
branches coming at you but he said j-dub
is forced to say this as an out-of-state
Edition are you saying they send you
like a list of things that you have to
say are we saying you've been bought no
I'm just willing to okay cuz listen I've
been given I've given Sony a ton of
years I've given Microsoft for 20 years
Microsoft needs more folders and
everything else I've supported all of
these companies in Google write to me
will it change the game day one no we
won't
but the future and the groundwork is
there I remember back in the day when
Sony bought
was it uh Gagarin yes right
that was like oh man this is a big deal
but guess what that didn't reap the
rewards until recently you know how many
years go back to Xbox Live the original
og Xbox Microsoft ear dead right ad
didn't reap the rewards into the
following generation in that offender
barrier for the industry I fill out and
so who knows where this Google stadia
right this may be the foundation to
where it needs to be maybe Microsoft and
maybe Sony are not the companies that
can get it over the barrier I mean we've
had PS now doing this exact same day
remote play and doing the exact same
thing since 2013 20 2014 and that hasn't
really pushed a berry you need more
people and I do understand and listen
this I want you guys to notice y'all
love the slip by this man has everything
he is not broke okay
and y'all sitting your fight over broke
versus rich police station versus X bar
this man just told you he brought the
founders addition to stadium oh wow
alright so you're gonna get out of your
feelings right now man get out of your
feelings I did by the the stadia edition
thing is I stopped that I had it I
purchased it and I counsel my order
because something in my gut told me this
was not going right when that didn't
came out with those red slippers I'm a
visual dude read bogus slippers out and
it was just like clown shoes to me
something I plan to me I'm not gonna get
his clown my money so I took my money
back right I say this it was well
warranted because I see all the missteps
is going on and Kratos is right a lot of
these features that we have on this
PlayStation 4 when it's
Xbox we didn't have in the beginning we
were fighting for a lot of these
features the same thing with switch we
don't have a lot of features that we
want right in the beginning because they
have to work those and because remember
they scrapped a lot of their user
interface to start off a new right and I
see what he's talking about these guys
is walking in a space where Sony and
Microsoft is supposed to dance on their
heads yes right they're supposed to box
these the guys out right now kill the
Beast while he's wounded a friend of
mine tells me that all the time
kill the Beast while he's wounded right
now he's wounded he's weak he's wounded
discouraged them very early out the gate
and shout-out to Lord Phil for doing
that you know he made it very obvious
that 50 games is inside X cloud um to
put them on a deal way put him on a slab
zip him up put the toe tag on to get him
out of there because if they happen to
get a headpiece team Kratos knows like I
know like he said they got that big
bread bin ik bread can be a game-changer
at any point in time and it says you
y'all know YouTube is so much far retied
you know we think of it we're gamers so
we're in the Xbox ecosystem we're in the
PlayStation ecosystem YouTube is so much
more far-reaching than that and for our
rating in gaming that the applications
are kind of mind-boggling
the thing about Stadium for me that just
it just feels tone-deaf is that I don't
I think they do a if they do not switch
over to a subscription service this
you're not I'm sorry you're telling me
that you asking me to pay full price for
a game that I could bid I can purchase
and play locally on another platform you
want me to pay full price and have faith
in that this service is gonna be here
five years down the line ten years down
the line that's it sounds super
tone-deaf sovereign this this it's so
tone-deaf in pain exactly what you're
saying is every game on that list except
for their glyph game is old is old and
it's and that's the thing they haven't
announced pricing on knows what if they
decide oh um shadow the Tomb Raider
we're gonna charge you fifty nine
nineteen and apparently they're hiding
the 4k aspect of their service behind a
paper you can do that right now
yeah listen these these some valid
points I mean arm it's okay okay keep in
mind right I gotta I gotta be fair here
mm-hmm
they came out the gate and said they
don't want to be a Netflix style service
they are not trying to see me freeze
eggs clock they're not trying to be the
game passive gaming that's not them
that's not the route of it they had
right they're looking forward they're
looking forward to a totally different
service a totally different service
meaning you don't have to go out and
spend five and six hundred dollars on
the console right now in the conference
bring your money on the games and pleum
any and everywhere mm-hmm and you can
play 1080p d3 or if you want the 4k HDR
you know surround sound as well as the
free games that comes every month or
whatever they nets products they're
selling point for that nine dollars a
month
oh but technically the service is free
but the issue I have with that is okay
so at that point your did your sort of
diva they're devaluing the need for a
console right the Xbox is doing the same
thing they're telling you they're gonna
give you a super powerful console but
they're saying you can do this I find
nothing wrong with this right
competition breeds rewards for us
fellas listen phil has a philosophy that
he's gonna buy in a direction he's going
by who has the one that they're gonna go
by Sony has on it they're gonna go buy a
Nintendo hasn't won a toga let the best
man win
right I don't know find this threatening
no not again I grabbed I I agree with
that totally but the thing is when you
had when the competition is front and
center in front of you you see what
they're doing you compare what you're
doing to them right but there's there
are obvious differences in value yes
obviously both feel Spencer and you know
obviously both Sony and Microsoft and
see this as a potential competition
because they ended up linking up yes and
got deep pockets correct we run this
gaming industry right now but man we
came that these guys come and
this room and not to cut you Jade also
there's a there's a there's a strong
rumor that in reference to why both Sony
and Microsoft have been making these
studio acquisitions you should prevent
them from falling in the hands even even
he said this next generation it's all
about the studio it's all about but who
can buy that who can buy the studios
it's all about acquisitions and that's
why you see feel and that's why you see
you know Sony and those guys buying up
your insomniac and University's got
their buying as much as they possibly
can because when Google come in and
start dropping millions now hundreds of
thousands but really on trying to
acquire these or I say here's the big
thing right I think in the short term
well Google is gonna go for those
marketing deals kind of high at the epic
store did when he came in and shook up
the PC industry what everybody was you
know Pro Steam now they come in and grab
that content exclusively on my platform
for a year for six months or whatever in
again Google hasn't shown their whole
hands in right you know again this
founder is only for the first set of
people who really want their hands on
this stuff but it's going on in the next
year
you know rolled it out to everybody else
and so on so some of the people that
pre-ordered very early the day of are
even was even so Kratos have you got for
mation
I just got my mind which mine is coming
a little beat at my house on the 21st
she's not only female it's exactly when
it's I'm glad that you know you get a
chance to touch and talk like a lot of
dudes or talk from a position of not
touching not owning and assuming right
right and in this day and age you're
able you afforded the luxury this
because this is a luxury gaming this
luxury guys this is not a rite of
passage you don't purchase a game
console and become a genie this
this this is a luxury because this is
disposable income that we're using to
further our hobby is a hobby and to
touch and to explain we we you can touch
everything somebody put in Twitter this
week that oh just to have everything
you're greedy in your unshorn you on
your choices no you're not ensuring your
choices you have a more disposable
income than the next guy so you're able
to purchase and you just don't want to
be without certain games I'm not gonna
get Luigi on xbox so for him to let you
know that a peek into his world that
he's gonna be playing stadia and he's
taking a lumps for you because us early
Optus when we purchase this stuff we're
taking the hits we're getting the
shortchange of the stitch
you know when y'all guys come on later
on and you'll get these stay Diaz let's
say I pick up stadia in February it's
gonna be a totally different stadia that
was in launched in November you can you
know I can talk to Kratos oh what
changed over a period of time since you
had it and we can talk from a position
of ownership after so young you guys
have to get out of your feelings save
those pennies and move up to purchase
more stuff so you can tell people from a
different aspect on Twitter not a not a
position of hate but a position of
ownership and explain why you don't like
some yeah I mean I can call me a
collector can cover you in it and it's
true at this point in my life I have a
lot more disposable income than I have
time to play what the thing is like I
don't want to be left out the
conversation even if it's an hour worth
of game that could give it right before
the podcast I think that has value and
we are content creators and influencers
in the gaming industry whether we like
it or not no matter how small your word
on a game has weight behind it because
another person has been exposed to that
game will come and say hey what do you
think about this I mean whatever you
tell him that tends to influence me so
you have to think about that so I'm a
down on what King said guys a lot of
stuff is for entertainment Joe
it's the funnest the fun is all it's all
fun rice there's no hatred and it's all
love so please do not take any of that
stuff as as Kenya that we're doing this
stuff right and we are day one adopters
of stuff think about all the stuff we
bought back in the day the verge the
Nintendo Virtual Boy the the you know
just on and on and on and on you're even
last generation with the whole place
move stuff make an act now this stuff
was leading up to where we're gonna be
within the next five to ten years this
is good discussion I love what
everybody's doing here um here's a deal
where I'm at and y'all know I'm kind of
what's funny is I've kind of started off
with Jada was that the sense of
obviously as a techie I loved the new
technology and where the industry may be
going and we all got the sense that
streaming was common right we knew we
call Gugu the white walkers right we
call it a record he is like everybody's
got a band up in the castle Winterfell
they're coming you know saying Knight
Kings covered so when this thing started
now something alright let me see what
they have and at the end of the day I
renew it's gonna force Sony and
Microsoft to step up their services and
the way they offer things right and I
think that's the good thing about what
the state is assistance is you know I'm
saying because now in my opinion based
on what happened with EXO with that part
of that cloud we don't get to the rest
EXO but just what extra projects cloud
to me I felt like and stuff really
dropped a blow on them and in the sense
that okay first of all we know the
twelve titles that's coming right for
statement and that's fine you know
that's cool but for them to say okay
right now we got 50 titles for you to go
touch to go do on all projects name and
I'll grant it not everyone has actually
it is an invite-only thing but the fact
that they open it up to more regions
it's going over to Canada it's going
over to India you know I'm saying like
regions that for the most part will
always consider like hey are we gonna
get access to that stuff that's a huge
deal but to me where they really knocked
it out the park and and addict was there
we did like was the EA acquisition the
EA acquisition was huge on two fronts
one cuz now I'm allowed to speak about
a Monday under NDA but ei was doing
their own thing they were due and I got
a chance to touch so the fact that they
are now on stage with Microsoft is a
huge deal and I'm saying is the one or
two things they're stepping away from
their thing or they're saying hey we're
not ready to really go all out and
Microsoft's in better position so let's
not move away from this this bread
you're never saying like in a sense
Saudi hand yeah like do matter we
already talked about it man is it one
MPD's like two months in a row like
regardless of how we feel about banning
the casuals the Pfeiffer's and then you
got apex left like that's a huge
partnership for X cloud you know me so
we got that and then to meet on the
deathblow was to me state and I had this
conversation carboxyl to me stay Diaz
advantage was the fact that look
everybody gonna want to attach it and
fall into this let's be real right we or
may not do it the kids may do but not
everybody some people like braaap they
make like yo I don't want that small
screen so when they made the
announcement like yo this is coming to
Windows 10 pcs and modern devices huge
because that's the lane stadia plays it
because for the most part is their
mobile is only locked to a specific
phone you can't use any other Android
device you know I'm saying that kind of
thing so you got again you got that then
they're saying game pass is now included
with the server so you make game pass
now sexy right because now just by
having game pass boom you can stream
your X cloud games to them that's a huge
deal and there's games that are still
not in game past that up that x5 has
already besides the Madden's they had
Tekken 7 and all this other stuff it's a
huge deal man again I know it's early
I'm never gonna discount something
automatically you know obviously we got
to see how the Google thing plays out
but you know Phil's he was talking
strong into you that he did this this
was the first one in here declare it off
you guys just in case you didn't know
that he was stomping in the yard right
now this is not political field that
he's on a stage
he's working out background checks with
uh you know Sony making sure everything
check out right and giving them some
service so we can get this moving and
what what a good King does with a good
King does is he makes sure that the
squad is right you know if your team is
right because right around Sony is on
the squad to Nintendo's on squad to he
knows who he needs to go forward to stop
these dudes you do not want I had
everybody talk about game passes back
and you do not want stadia or what's the
next do with Amazon's these means
getting a hold of our gaming hobby you
do not want that to turn into all these
little pop games and all this little
stuff that little like gem games that we
play you don't want that to happen our
our John row but we're trying to control
and keep the integrity of our gaming
alive
so if y'all gonna sit there and not
support he told you they're dead
we got games in the mix right now and
we're gonna jump on these screens we're
gonna go where they play it we're gonna
go to their yards and we're gonna beat
them back so dude they got that
dragonglass
and they bought this finish we just
talked about next cloud versus stadia
they still have console streaming right
so people would not in areas that have
the strongest you know a connection or
whatever they may be they can go to
their local console and stream games to
if let's say for somehow some reason you
have a game that isn't in game pass or
is it part of the X cloud thing you can
still stream whatever's on your system
that's a huge deal man and I just you
guys and that's where it is I think that
the key word in all of this is choice
versus lack of choice yes stadia doesn't
give you a choice stadia is very sort of
direct and I would dare to say kind of
stagnant in the amount of choice that it
gives you and whereas X cloud just just
especially with this announcement has
said it's all about like it's literally
all about choice you engage with this
however you feel works for you we're
going to give you a bunch of different
avenues and you figure it out Stadium is
not bad
I think you know so other nouns I wanted
to give the cradles was that all it also
kind of reminds me not again no
disrespect they stated this would be
like this could be the route right that
could be the way but you gotta sometimes
just hi like Microsoft my step with the
digital only future we all know what
eventually is going in but sometimes too
aggressive in the rip you turn people
off and I'm just worried that because
there's so aggressive girl console only
you know you don't need you don't saying
you and then you have to buy a separate
thing that that could end up being a
factor that the other two may ended up
surpassing them but that's what I had to
say I guess alright yeah it definitely
it could it could definitely be a case
of an idea that's out before its time
definitely let me tell you guys my
intentions for Google Stadium talk to me
it was not for me to be playing on an on
my cell phone
listen yeah we all wait we got two hours
per day listen Nintendo switch is
pushing it right it's pushing it you
know but it's pushing it for me so I
that that is that was not and that's not
my main you know not X cloud great is
not for me because I don't want to play
right I'm taking myself out that
equation rather but what about the
windows 10 announcement they sitting on
a PC even better even better even even
better but I already have game pass of
ultimate for that for my PC right so
that's already there origins premiere I
mean the EA origins premiere got that
alright no doubt so I did Welland dabble
in various services see how they are
what type of games that they give me in
that talk on a roll from that mm-hmm now
here's the thing with the Google stadia
let's go
alright I think a lot of people are
focusing more on the consoles aspect of
what competing but what the stadia do
for you you you know as a PC gamer have
a nice react to 20 but but this is my
thing with PC gaming I say Buddha let's
jump on some card has jumped on this
I gotta update the drivers all this
stuff that it makes me question why am i
spinning these thousands of dollars on
this consoles have always outdone pcs
and how to here it's the ease of you
need just so guess what now you're
telling me they work I will have 10.17
flops to work with no loading gaming
wants to come back and finish them where
I finished off it
it was benefits in those aspects 4k HD
are you know very attractive to you I
asked well there is more attractive to
me that's what this stuff is on my PC so
I mean so much TV so when I travel from
hotel to hotel I'm gaming that's the eye
candy for me wrap everything else could
all just be a plus I may or may not try
to use it yet but I just want to explain
you nailed it I mean for your situation
and there's a there's people like you
don't get me wrong I get it again shot
the carboxyl he's in a similar situation
and I'm saying like you know they're
people who are not going to want to do
that you know whole PC setup and the
drivers and all that and it's literally
you don't have to download it it's ready
to go
all that sexy I guess you're completely
right I just want to look at it from
sometimes I think as the hardcore
sometimes we worried about ourself which
we should we should only worry about
ourselves but I don't think about for
the masses like you know little Joey or
whoever that's playing fortnight
whatever like is like I'm just trying to
figure out besides the hardcore like
that or you got yourself who's the
target audience right to try cuz they
need to win right there's not a lot of
you running around in it everybody not
balling like the Kratos I just want to
know if they're gonna this message is
gonna be able to resonate with little
joy who may have a console or whatever
or someone who has an Xbox to say hey
why am I gonna pay for another copy of
destiny or another copy of this when I
got it on X cloud and I got game past
and I could just literally throw this on
well I have PlayStation now and I got or
late you know they've got
exclusives and their games on it that
that's something I'll tell you I'll tell
you why right talking this could be
focused in various ways be disgruntled
you see guys that are tired of spending
thousands to addict or over the gamers
that want to get into gaming without you
know the man who wants to buy the
scarlet eventually but doesn't want to
spend five six hundred dollars on that
and don't have it maybe a guy that plays
plays games every now and then guess
what
eventually that chrome stick is going
away eventually there's an app inside of
our TVs model with an update that allows
you to do that all you need would need
is a controller so again day one know
it's gonna be so hard sale for a lot of
people day one but day 365 it could be
very much viable we made we we most
definitely will be having a totally
different conversation notices and
strategically I've always told you that
I liked the way that fill things and he
has box these dudes into a weird type of
corner right because I just listened to
Jay don't say that you know financially
right financially there's a program that
you can get an ex right now game pass
ultimate for two years and pay as little
as thirty dollars a month the same way
you use your phone service now the fact
that X cloud is rolled into the game
past ecosystem when it is rolled out to
the masses and everybody is accepted
into this ecosystem with the game X
cloud and they're starting to put it on
various screens see my biggest wish is
when I go to e3 I don't got to pack up
my xbox with me last year we purchased a
giant controller with over 3,000 games
and we were playing it in our compound
and this year the hope is when we go out
to e3 we just take our controllers with
us
and we're just booting up and playing
right there I don't have to worry about
I can be on my raids at night if we're
not party we do videos and a team is
there and we're all doing a raid
together in the same room on the screens
you know um that's my dream of where
exhale can go I see
Phil allowing those individuals that
don't have the the purchasing power of a
kratos to to get in at the low price it
is just a dollar a day basically and you
work your way up and win-win that's the
Scarlet does come out you send that
system back and you get a scarlet and
you still in the ecosystem you still go
Alexis program right and it's a genius
move without a doubt I agree with you
mandate Microsoft have put themselves in
a stern position for their base and for
like-minded people who are willing to
have all the games the great values that
come with it and the hardware without a
doubt they have thought this stuff
through you know I would never act them
for absolutely real quick
shot on the braaap of the Fowler super
chat no way Jana PC master-race all day
the best things in life do that King you
know these dudes got bad credit
listen man I had a very ignorant mind
when it comes to stuff like that I used
to say anybody can afford I mean it's
only so far but again I had a very
ignorant mind that is not the cakes out
of different countries and a lot of
different territories around in again it
makes that that much easier imagine next
year when the Xbox one and the ps4 drops
down to 149 what's funny
that that is what the bulk of the sales
from this generation is probably gonna
come up trust me we are not Brazil South
America and stuff like that may they
just just just watch those watch those
sales numbers go up yeah well we own the
fives and whatever the Xbox is they
gonna be buying them full yes was the
same reason the same way yeah that sucka
didn't really kick off in price until it
came down about $99 and damn it it is
another twenty twenty-five thirty
million
we gotta move oh but I just want to get
that out with the whole S cloud stadia
thing it's gonna be interesting man Xbox
Xbox definitely dropped some bombs but
we got the rest of the show what's so
long you know propped up my chair we've
got a big topic right now XO ninety this
week interesting very polarizing feeling
about their reaction to the show
shout-out to Lord addict myself kids
whoo that's a good we did a live
reactions you know they're so good to me
so you know we gotta go start this off
with the Lord's man I mean obviously you
know there was a lot shown a lot
discussed so I want to bring to the
roundtable I won't actually arm solve I
know you didn't get to see everything
but I want actually start with you first
you know just initially off the
announcements you know anything that
moved you anything I didn't you know
kind of thing what was your vibes and
then we're moving the cradles and
everyone else your everyone else bushes
alright so let's get Adi addicts woke it
up no no I'm a man
everybody had it okay okay so let's do
it so um obviously we just talking about
the s cough stuff that was huge to me
that was the biggest thing to really
come out of this is a know the boot to
the stadia neck um that that was just in
the fact that they're expanding it now
quickly um so they still didn't really
specifically give a time when it's
actually launching proper and I think
that's going to be closer to when you
know when the actual next console
launches where they're gonna have this
really set in stone what they're going
to do with this but the fact that they
were letting more and more people in
shows the confidence they have in it and
obviously once you give people more
content people are gonna be really gonna
hold to try it so that was big um
everything else I know people had issues
with you know obsidians announcement
grounded and obviously ever wild for
from I'm rare with the city we don't
mention grounded I say this I have
issues with all of these side projects
look a during you are tuning that's all
about let's get to it
every because it just gives it and again
it could be fantastic but it does give
it this air of it does it's not the
quality of our other stuff it that's it
you know fair enough why would I think
that way right it's just when you're
looking at a user base that's comprised
a lot of adults often time looking at
you look at a game like this from a
studio that just release an RPG that you
know it is kind of beloved by everyone
and is in their lane to do something
different I'm like cool it's something
different it just it looks like it's not
for me it looks like it's for my nephew
ROM so that mmm whatever we'll see you
know I'm not a big fan of survival games
the whole Honey I Shrunk the Kids feels
feels like it could be cool we'll see
let's get sovereign legs in the book you
shut out the Lord of implies deaf
singing sex so tight II was eight point
five out of ten age of empires for
graded
last of us - i won't i won't do that
slander death you're onto something
could keep that energy with no soul so
then so that you know whatever um ever
wild i mean if you look at rares
pedigree yeah
rare making a game that looks like this
is not surprising some right it's with
their pedigree um it has a painterly
sort of breath with a wild type look we
don't know what the game is
I'm glad you said that say this I said
it looked more gorgeous than breath in a
while let's keep it up octo whatever
that was gaming a year sometime and you
know what y'all wanted these games that
come out so oh boy you know was the law
you know what the the best compliment
you can get somebody is to copy them so
we gonna copy a move on do it better
I like the birds fly in I like looking
good and it definitely gave me that
brother I say yeah you know what I think
you want something you but my son was
sitting there my son said Oh daddy so do
nothing for you know what it is it
sounds like Christmas and little kids
want these toys and all of this this is
this is all game past day one right all
game past day one you'll want to get
some killer-diller stuff go go get play
rage - right now is in game let's pay
the bill real quick out of five dollars
super chat from Lord debt singer we
waited 15 years for a new age of empires
and field dominance gave me exactly what
I wanted Jim Ryan better start making
RTS games you know you're on which way
did it get announced remember watching
all they have the mouse and keyboard
it's on peace
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
we gotta be listen he's gonna get me the
game on my PC now this great you don't
wanna play just review a muted you
didn't go seek it to play it not talk
about it you reviewed it listen there he
go everybody get those fraud alerts out
for a lot of frauds on this all the
hundred some people that's in here you
see that join button join the join us
you see the chat put these stuff up in
here these frauds you can use the fraud
alert although I have like eight days in
Halo Wars I've like
you know you know you gotta fight off
super chats gamer ever while look good
Adrienne prize for look fantastic
wasteland 3 look great tell me why why
will be a great story and flight sim is
the best graphics decision and that's my
this is my worry with everyone right
though if it's if it's some if it's a
game like see if thieves I would be
tight I just want I just want fish man I
think it's a good thing it could happen
I just want to open it I want an
experience that is an RPG like or
whatever the case may be action game
whatever case maybe I don't want all of
these other
alright so also aspects to the game just
give me a game we got a $5 tip a chat
from black every world could be a games
as a service station that's what he
means
so my opinion I do not want to know
their games deserves from rent Thank You
Microsoft hasn't used rare since to 360
Microsoft really did use rather than 360
[Laughter]
give me cameo to I want to I'm sure the
day let's be real here a lot of the the
IPS that rare used they wouldn't sell in
this this job
John they wouldn't like put a banjo
kazooie at let's see how well it really
does budget lately you don't have like
the hardcore pickup bed you kazooie this
good and it's I could've sell thing is
if you were to come back with banjo dad
manager I love the quality of a Mario
game it has to be quality I don't mind
rare doom betrayers doing I mind what if
city is doing because it's why peach
game talk about rare so Jason drag each
game the game look good that's what
we're likes to do when I do this
narrative that Microsoft's Porsche
Carerra make a let's remember this
sentiment is too like this this game is
grounded it's a small sideshow team
teams doing it man like you can't expect
me as an obsidian fan their RPG fabric
to go for something like your survival
gave the neck wait till I go oh well I
know I feel the same
that's trend over don't play it is in
game past date and date you got choice
sir I hold all okay I got a cup at your
neck it's kickoff for so here's the big
so it just cuz its gamepads we don't
have to worry about no quality there's
no quality control interested in a game
is not quality I'm not seeing it all I'm
saying is that we to addicts point
quality they literally switch that's
fine to talk about even mad at that with
mad
all I'm saying is we gotta understand
coming off of outer worlds that we all
feel right so and again no this game
could be fired in your defense this game
could be fun but you gotta understand
you can't get you add some more gameplay
foolish you just coming up off that type
of outer world and then they see honey i
shrunk the kids it would the cartoony
joint and being sick that's all
let me say when we go to two packs or we
go to e3 we go to different shows yes um
there is main Lords group and then we
have a side group that goes off and they
do their videos and stuff like that and
they have a whole different technique in
how they present their stuff do you
write this now and and how they can use
their the expression right so you get
different interviewing style from them
as you will get a different interview
style from like let's let's say let's
people but this is a smaller group that
was that's cool and everything but as an
aspect to someone that played the
Fallout New Vegas is that play the outer
wards that played the south parts like
it's one thing if it was like you know
they made something smaller but they
stay to their true roots but you can't
expect the fans of this studio to be
okay going to drastic change but okay to
say I don't think the smaller thing was
out of worlds
Jade oh you saw when Sony allowed those
do to make that game on the the girl
with the bow and the snow because you
don't want to compare because
graphically it doesn't match up to that
game that game that company was a
drastic departure normally I would
normally put out so j-dub if everybody
took that same attitude toward zero
horizon going known for that and
remember a lot of the rhetoric going up
to it was that studio ace is known for
that totally third party Nani
I don't think you understand the term
you're looking for more mature tiles it
doesn't mean it's not quiet I'm not
saying it's not quite this is where
y'all y'all losing me right now and
we're gonna get straight to it here's
the thing you can't get mad at people
who are disappointed with how that game
looks you don't saying you can't get mad
at people who just came off of outer
worlds right no one saying the game's
not quality better - oh you're gonna get
that no one say it's not quality but you
gotta understand that they you there are
gonna be a group of people who are gonna
be disappointed especially especially
when we are touting this as the most
powerful console and all and then when
they see these cartoony graphics right
especially when the majority of the
shows we gonna just get to it had that
level of grad the same level of graphic
for a lot of these exclusive they were
telling you people some people are not
gonna feel it for the longest time for
for the longest time I always said guys
get over it
[ __ ] there get over they make him
bleeding edge it's a smaller team city
and I'm with you dizzy this is boo let's
get down let's go world's people that
are fans of their games and then you go
from the stuff they make the core their
fan base to a multiplayer gap it's gonna
make and shout out to real whatever
uncle Udo he said horizon d rizal
definitely not a project we always get
down on people making a scene
they done switched it up listen ma'am
game Pass is it has to get younger it
was a year ago or whatever so you know
why because this is the focus and you're
not you're not focused scared that
they're doing this stuff because a game
pass today I agree what did you what you
have to understand is there was no games
there right there they're moving forward
in making an ecosystem that is friendly
enough cuz remember just reverse right
we win we're on to Xbox whatever that is
and PlayStation eyes they have made
their service with s's so these games
can still be run right so when these
systems is selling and you get getting
passed and a xbox day a sad system and
you tell your son your daughter whoever
you nephew your whoever you pray for
them you want to know that there's a
bunch of games in there that they can
play as well they don't need to be Luna
shooter killers they don't does fun have
to be it created in hyperrealism games
gave you something different let me
respond to you on this ain't King here
let me you us drop an acknowledge right
I feel diversity right we can't all have
photorealistic all the time right we
can't have a ludus you everything you're
saying is true but here's my issue right
again when you make these announcements
right you got all these studio
acquisitions you got the Obsidian got
all this beats to do they making bangers
right we see ninja theory with the
hell-blade oh my god it's ridiculous
right the vibe I get when they come out
on stage it almost feel like this was a
negotiation in order fulfilling to get
the studio right I don't I feel like get
it big it's like yo we gonna sign with
you my baby my man is freaky Zika do god
they got two little games they never
drop yet
yeah you need to promote this right here
this is a passion but these are the bars
the album is the loss teams that should
feel like the Lost Tapes
album yeah right yes okay let's not act
like in all of this stuff and all of
these purchases they don't have games
and thoughts that they're doing that
money came in right right and he's like
you Jimmy remember the game getting this
hot ain't got nothing why not don't they
want a Greek war you show a definite
record and we what you got boss I do
feel like if you're gonna do this
drastic change in which you make like
when you and now it's grounded show game
play show what the games about don't
have some vague thing of a dude struck
in a world trying to survive cuz cuz
it's not good that's that's gonna run
wait no bleeding games like at least you
kind of got a concept about bleeding
edge was about we literally know nothing
about grounding
what about associated killing game with
the cowboy oh I like that I like that's
the one that got robbed coming is doing
the voice for mom and I want to chase
spy was let's get to let saw finish then
we gotta get credit I get in it's not an
attack on on the perceived quality of
the game but that's that's the issue
right immediately you look at that and
you look at it as a kiddie game and you
look so immediately as an adult it's not
right to think that way but immediately
it's like it's not for me it's not for
me and that's with the momentum they
have I'm like give me something else I'm
appreciative of the variety I'm
appreciative of the fact that they're
willing to allow them to do this before
they make something bigger or the next
big thing whatever their core thing is I
really do appreciate it it just feels
like it it's not for me so it's
disappointing let me ask you let me ask
solve a question in Kingston
what about for the let's be real right
we know switches winning out here right
so like what about ting defense that the
diversifying that the portfolio having
more of those type of games as well as
like for example I was at a Catania I
was pissed off during the car racing
anything that went one way too long for
me but right I didn't know after
watching it the show that I guess that
game on PC is like the million is
millions of people like this is like a
revered piece million caught racing game
right so what are the kings defense what
about him saying like well maybe filter
on the first time I found out the
portfolio and then also appeal to a
broader audience outside of us or is it
your thing is like y'all where at least
show us some more photorealistic game
show us a little bit more games for me
like what do you answer to that you're
not completely agree I mean but I'm
coming to our game past for specific
sort of things right and not to sake I
love I love indie games I love something
that draws my eye right I absolutely get
it it just feels that when when it comes
to Microsoft when you're getting when
you're getting a sideshow thing right
well we're expecting we want a big
reveal right we always want a big reveal
we don't get the big reveal we get the
sideshow thing the sideshow thing always
looks cartoony like it's definitely not
for us and then please good job read him
yeah he said what's the what's about
them what about the more realistic games
CrossFireX flight sim all the new Final
Fantasies Yakuza don't be distracted by
the artistic looking game absolutely
we're exclusives none of the day like it
is looking like you know from the
outside looking in it's looking like
that they're starting to make the
majority of their games like this well
let's just say it let's just say the
games that are not big like obvious
because we can't say gears it's like
that right we can't it feels like the
news I know you're going out you feel
like the acquisitions outside making
those shows or anything so you is no
need to do no heavy hitting bomb
blasting stuff
we've already established that you know
so it's okay cuz it's going in game past
okay because it's going in game past see
this is what we have to do as game and
said we have to get out of this bubble
way if it don't we are selfish
of course right if it didn't hit on you
it's garbage
right if you didn't hit on you I don't
care about it if it don't you usually
start a narrative I said it's most of
the same things I was like okay well
that's cool
my son is sitting on the couch or watch
and he's hidden he's like also you gonna
download that daddy when I come I be at
Xbox and Sweden mr. Longridge Iraqi no
idea tech Fox said when those games is
released on idea that's why stay
released in game past date and date you
can get a chance to get a lot of those
indie games that people act about
remember because the Indies have went
the way of the dinosaur with other
companies but they of a land to fall and
flourish but check it out right let's
say let's say the initiatives games
comes out right Alti million dollar
games your solve don't do it any and
it's just and it's all the perception is
gonna be it's not triple-a episode is
this one was it to write this down I
want y'all to look at this this this is
where nice matches sovereign music first
when I looked at outer wilds a game that
is gonna be in game of the year
conversations and said knives and bushes
that played it is trash
that was not no it's not a game
fantastic it's fantastic you look at it
you would like nope no no
I was saying I want your knees right now
because you're defending exactly what
you did not do when I look at the outer
walls that gave me trash this is it was
objectively not trash things and change
up narratives and twist up words this is
your job that's not my job he's head
right now go
it's a you I know you you know you can't
pull this on me right you might put me
on the King links on the little King Lee
listen we're not gonna allow you to sit
there and tell me I didn't play out I
downloaded it before you none for you
that's not true right that's not true at
all off my heart yeah that is not true
at all garbage I played why is it
garbage tell me why is garbage
why tell me what garbage I wanted to
play out of worlds no no it was out of
worlds I said what does that have to do
with why that game is garbage
oh you why I hated the game it was
another game now he's gonna describe a
totally different game that has nothing
to do out of a while you loved it and I
find a garbage that's something that you
got to get over but you found that you
specifically said you already sniffed
hold on hug on card if he not
specifically said I looked at that game
and I was like no no wild one a society
a garbage trash any why is that game
garbage time
Oh y'all know if you're put on auto why
is that game good something you wouldn't
no because you did not play you did late
you turned it on and you look at the
little alien you was like nada say trash
why do you not why can't you describe
why I saw trash because it's garbage
doesn't answer that my nephew would give
me because dummies is my bro knees a
mine for the rest of the year beating
that game you gonna know you're gonna
play that game play that game it's not
even in game pass for me I deleted it I
deleted the little dancing game practice
it is a game back to the actual question
you gonna tell me you gonna tell me that
if if the initiative the game come up
comes out and if it looks like a
stylized game what's the perception
gonna be what's the box game does crane
you've been okay not not now to kick
this off to Kings Point if you mishit of
comes out and it's photorealistic it's
very high quality don't my paper this
with the cops right now but this is the
point I never argued that I said my
question is how would you feel about
that game if it came out trash I'm done
with that conversation those knees are
mine but yo this is not you know how you
take a baby when they're crying and then
you try to distract them take me head-on
he's the one that brought up knees for
no reason alright it was give a scenario
but the challenge has been issued so
whatever challenge so that's what that's
what I'm trying to the thing is I'm not
saying I'm not saying - did you hear
okay so that was it so there's no need
so there is no need cuz I thought I'd
always doing he was trying to say I did
the point if King saw the initiative in
the game look like the kind of or like
in King's defense he's putting his knees
all alone he's telling you is no way
initiative is gonna do that
no if that's not the argument the
initiative came out and they had a game
like that right no he wouldn't fill
argument is solve is out here making
proclamations that that game is gonna be
stylized scenario I gave what if what
would you feel if it came out that way
dealing what ifs are dealing yomi's know
every turn every time you walk up my
knees you lose all this right you have a
big offer with my knees in one right now
backwards compatible so I never said it
wasn't gonna be alright so there's only
Zola's solve it k go I'll let you finish
your points but we gotta get Kratos
it'll be waiting to jump in so I got it
this is crazy
oh just a little jumpy there's no DS
Kratos
okay he's like I'm just very EXO die
team is very intense so let's get to it
you know you saw the show I I saw your
Twitter before XO 19 about what you were
hoping for and everything and then after
so let's give your recap order EXO 19
sir alright so I we nee and I said look
I'm going to be positive about this
a bunch of my xbox brethren lowering
their expectations then don't don't
don't don't expect this don't expect
that and I said to myself why can I not
expect that why when it comes to Xbox in
Microsoft and their games everyone has
to temp their expectations but when it
comes to Nintendo in in PlayStation
those expectations have to go through
the roof three wasn't when if we ever
said you let nintendo direct you better
not have a load to taste I think we said
that Cognito it's just a wreck but don't
get you guys nobody in in Kratos his
defense he is right in the sense that I
just can't say all of the Xbox community
but some of the Xbox company coming in
the show not o not kidding not kidding
laser light now you is it this lot that
I did see say yo Tim I was guilty I see
your temper expectations
it's a Kratos his point he said why why
do we have to temper why can't we
continue Kratos
yeah and again it's it's you know again
I try to say why is that why why we
shoot you can't hype something for
PlayStation because they do an offense
right oh that's true right Sony don't
have the offense but here's the thing
right just because you have an event you
act like that's a W when Microsoft had
to stage but to themselves and Sony
still ended up with a demo so you know
you got Sony does not feel like they
have competition right now in the show
let's party so you put listen in none of
you guys do you guys can do speed this
Stoney can light the internet on fire
with one tweet one single something that
feel and Microsoft
do they cannot now when you have the
mind share when you have the bangers
when you have the meaningful stuff that
people talk about that's long lasting
only being in band when you when you got
to go you don't have to show up you can
just drop at week right before somebody
else event and shut that whole thing no
no listen I'm glad Microsoft for having
these events this is a great fan fest
event this is a great event to show you
what they have coming but I now want to
get to my point let's get the problem
was you know that was one thing why
can't we have these high standards why
can't me get height for this stuff why
do we have to learn expectations it may
show you something this should be a
level of expectations they own and and
in number two - my point is after the
show I realized something I had a
revelation oh right and I finally you
guys will see cradles changing Oh field
ominous has changed me okay I bend the
knee oh listen I'm giving it I'm giving
it to you let me tell you do you know
wait it let me tell you why let me tell
me hit it I realize one thing EXO 18 I
mean EXO 19 is the feature of Xbox oh
this is exactly why I feel is not what
Microsoft or even the Xbox fan base
looking and finally came to that right I
need to stop trying to force my agenda
only looking for forum feel I need to
stop looking for
the highly graphical showcase sellers to
showcase the power of the Tifa I need to
stop forcing my will upon me I realized
that all those 24 25 40 games whatever
they show that is a great value for game
that's a great value in game past is the
future of Xbox games at the check he
bought all these Studios working on
these games they show the future of Xbox
and I said okay you know what I'm cool
with that I will no longer go and talk
bad about Xbox or feel for doing when
there have been asking for them my ex
fellow Xbox brother highly critical for
one you high peak will be PlayStation as
well by the way 78% of PlayStation guys
bought the worlds of the game no choice
but to buy because it wasn't available
for you to buy it by the right I get it
if I want the big bangers
greater one thing I do realize right is
that guys Wilkinson tweet it out guys
I've tweeted out right now guys either
way we have to wait for the games
but I realize they are never coming the
games this generation isn't over I know
you guys are seeing what the generation
overs they focus on next year but let me
tell you what let me tell you what sony
has yet to in this generation now next
generation this generation is getting a
class of us to go Tsushima BAM
we speak a project awakening our movie
are a ton of other games damage
generation right I wish they have
bullets in the gun but the big bullets
right movie all this that's gonna force
you yes I spit force Oh to get out of
later and bond a PlayStation fire
because you know only for 60 frames per
second we gonna stop this Maximus pencil
let's get it now so when you know Phil
was laying down the groundwork nobody
can build a house on Ash on Stan right
so a year ago game past looks a totally
different than what I look now everybody
there's no games in it now a year ago
they didn't have what is it companies
developers they went on purchase those
he is now Sony took five six years maybe
seven years on certain games to be
coming to don't even announced a new
game listen six seven years from we just
purchased those studios now you see a
minor food so those labels being thrown
in game passed on side projects that
they were doing don't don't get amped up
don't don't don't start filling yourself
right now because there's nobody
that's OSHA bang y'all star P three
people keep saying well we're gonna wait
to me a brother we've been waiting for
five years let you rock let's rock let
you spit your bars right these bars now
y'all done had your five years
you you you starving right now you
hungry right now you really want that
last of us to so bad it's only keep
pushing that plate further further down
you can't get to that plate we keep
putting out these meals mm-hmm this
belly full belly
you hungry right now empty so listen
when y'all get to chance to see what
we're gonna show at e3 when you chance
to see what those games look like that
poor narrative is done you you're no
longer the fastest mm-hmm your people
threw that out and then he took that
right back mm right you're no longer the
power most powerful their people's gonna
say that they can't say that no it's
totally different now now the games are
coming you gonna give us the five years
that y'all took five years remember
y'all launched just this generation with
no games y'all would be friendly Indies
in the bush as soon as you got one
banger the next banger it was surviving
off the fact that y'all was a budget
system yo that was cheaper yeah right so
people purchase y'all guys because I was
$100 cheaper and you had a bunch of
indie games
it was y'all did it I can't say anything
wrong with it I have it but I'm not
gonna act like you're not gonna give us
the five years that y'all had to come
here to cultivate your own you have
that's a good point King like people act
like Sony dominated the entire
generation of transit games yeah they
did
Baker's every year well I would agree
with you let me ask one question I'm
glad that statement right there right
though you had the bangers you had your
eyes your son said over crimes you had
all of that stuff right
you got no sequels to number that and
yet that - oh no facts facts Tony's got
sequels that was it the conversation the
conversation is Sony did not have
bangers every year like people claim
there's a good three here they have
really good game to come out every year
the entire huge listen here is where
Microsoft feel right they did not invest
they literally did not invest for three
years years behind you by being three
years behind in order for them to catch
up that would mean in ten great Tony
would have to sit steal or not exactly
Metro for readers Kratos so you tell me
like in the beginning you had a winning
formula right yes alright so your
formula was winning those a team that
was in front y'all was moving and
shaking Kolkata
Kawara whoever okay we didn't have a
legit team we threw the iron out on his
head that seems to not be spoke one guy
just was there delicious let's not act
like he's we can't act like he had to
say we job was to be a part of game was
being part of games my boy is in charge
right now yes now wouldn't is it a turn
around yes or no did you just bend the
knee to him and not to Phil about you
yes sir Foreman with his fanbase expects
of him 19 all games will guess what the
ambles ask for you guys not asking for
them big blockbuster bang know what so
know how you can you honestly say that
like just because three people you
follow say we don't need giving me this
okay
so you're gonna tell me that we have the
same philosophy that we had in a
beginner the future of Xbox bright it
and it wasn't in it yes or no sure is
the easy brighter yes yes or no this is
why I'm like Michael Jackson and Chris
Brown together right now you did if you
again if you are brighter yes or no
that's all we want
yes or no question because you're asking
me right right a brighter for me and
what I meant what I expected in what I
want it no is not if you take me out
equation and what it's probably it's a
god saying obviously right because guys
hyped up everything that they saw and
you're loving it and therefore filled
keep giving you what you love and there
is no change it's why I finally came to
the conclusion his fan base with they're
asking for what they love is so he's a
change that for me let me say something
real quick
just give me my views of EXO real quick
and I got a penis please
being that j-dub doesn't want to give it
up and you know tell the truth let me
the vision of EXO is definitely doing
what they're supposed to be doing like
you saw glimpses of games that are
coming from little minor studios and
then you saw some of those are bigger
games like bleeding edge Ames's are
about to be released inside to the game
past March everybody knows going forward
game past is the thing all right they
throwing everything into game past they
even gave you EA access rolled up into
game paths even gave you Spotify rolled
into game past they giving you reasons
to latch on to game pass because going
forward they want to make sure that you
have enough high octane inside your
vehicle to get where you're going and
then when those games do come from those
big studios that took the years to
cultivate them and make them how you
want it what is it going to be then what
will be the narrative then see
everything isn't about certain gamers
gays wasn't for me my son didn't care
too much about that cel-shaded cowboy
game but he cared about the kart racing
he cared about the the little honey our
diversity that's what we're doing a bit
so you Holly diversity this is what this
is what I'll call it weird the diversity
and Sony sir when it comes to diversity
on PlayStation people like putting these
big spotlights on the big games but we
don't talk about the little crumbs that
fell on the Guara like the make the mid
evils that little paintbrush game like
look they have bangers they have
probably some of the best games that's
come out this generation no one's
denying that but we can't act like the
little ones it's that's let's try to get
a little bit of a spotlight don't exist
the Sony makes back in June I gotta pay
the bills you hold a JD gave it to an
awesome job because Xbox is holding big
shots until next-gen JD gamer again to
thousands which our money rules them all
Microsoft could by Sony tomorrow then
god I believe Jade I was the last one
from JD you know $10 which excuse me
j-dub you're the one that is it I missed
one get me JD game I like three 2020 on
fire house will burn right yeah JD gamer
j-dub you're the one that said that
Fanning was game of the year not I don't
count one Gossage Toshima to do it for
you either
PlayStation had three good gears 2017
2018 because 2019 isn't good for you all
right Jay mm good gives you Nick
well no let me finish at the end of the
day cuz this is why ii will say on this
topic if we just gotta realize babies
like music first off it's an EXO like
you know as much as you know EXO the
show was good at the end of the day EXO
is still excellent they show from what I
saw an EXO this year is this is first
off they've been very very transparent
they said we have they pretty much have
like two three teams on every studio
they wanna they want a triple-a recorder
and they want double a sprinkle between
them look that's why I said Sony has the
same end going they have smaller studios
make us up but the reason we don't talk
about those smaller games because
they're big edge of doing so well you
got obsidian that we know for a fact
making in another game [ __ ] there we
know for a fact making another game we
got a low you know the halo gives them
for is this stuff we are compulsion
which is hard to tell what they're
making I don't know there's their stuff
on the horizon the one good thing I will
say about EXO is that they're showing
this stuff and a lot of these games are
gonna be out before you three mm-hmm you
know sure if you some of these games
aren't for you you know one thing that I
could tell you about EXO is you know
we've had a huge issue with JRPGs on
xbox like a huge issue that's always
been overlooked where's clear came on
there was like we fixed in that we get
it we understand we fixing that right
sir there is a human there's no denying
it xbox had a really bad year in terms
about about generation quality but at
the end of the day you know it doesn't
make up for it it doesn't fix it it does
it may justify when you have a huge
demographic of people leaving and coming
in and the entire company's changing as
a whole which you see now is Sony in
reference to what Kratos said though
like do you feel that what created the
vibe I'm getting from you cradles is
this like do you feel because of all
these circumstances all that and you get
that part I'm getting the vibe that you
let you get that part with my soul but
the vibe I'm also getting from you is
that look when is enough enough that we
start demanding more like you almost
feel like throwing up your hands because
I see plenty of people asking for better
quality game you play to replant or
cradles are saying that what they're
giving you is they're giving you more
right it's not giving you more of what
we're perceiving as well
which is that you know the quote-unquote
PlayStation style game right third
person character action game beautifully
time acting exactly they show you if you
want if you want huge triple-a stuff you
know high quality they said they're
working on that they bought the studios
a year ago let's be realistic here it
takes more than a year to make those
kind of gaps you have to leave if you
don't want to wait I know you got a
Playstation I know you got a PC Xbox is
on the back burner
Citians said to CEO see it right let's
go new billion has gotten a million so
salute and this comes out late from the
Upstate and he said the Obsidian CEO and
I'll see you guys this has been on
Twitter another reason to my point of
sitting and CEO Fergus
you you yeah as a company on a smaller
scale despite the newly available
Microsoft resources okay wait wait
listen finish already to direct games
again worked on fallout 1 and to barda's
gate before looking to keep the studio
smaller and more nimble so he can again
according to Phil Spencer with his feels
presses on words
you crank out more content but it's
gonna be smaller content so have those
draw spills and draw days like we've had
of this new generation and I get that
and I applaud that but according to this
CEO he's looking even though feel cut
the check
he's look to keep the team on a smaller
scale I got an answer for that it would
be different these people were making
trash gains from the start obsidian has
always had these smaller studios they've
always made good games [ __ ] days
always had these smaller studios they
want a great game
I must say triple a from know people
that have always had is okay I'm not
expecting I'm expecting good games
I don't like I've said it multiple fun
Lord cognitive and I said multiple times
I do not like to turn triple-a right I
like good games right now the world's 86
on Metacritic
everyone loves I think but it's
perception perception is a college truth
listen that's a great quality game right
and that's the quarry is uh the the
something of Edith Finch
that's a great game right super lucky
still on a switch that's a great game
but when I go to store to the store and
stand outside of the lines to buy my own
salt in my system
the game I can't sleep at night because
I'm so anticipated in hyped for mmm-hmm
this is what I'm talking the games that
Microsoft showed at Expo nineteen I'm
gonna I'm not gonna lie Sony got
revealed we get those games that's in
our library every day of the week we get
games like advertisement right look
country Jeannie a great game you playing
in VR you there's not a great game not a
game is a good game you know games like
that you got you got stuff like that
they're a good that's right but here's
the thing if those things were to talk
to the Microsoft platform it oh my god
concretely the question
I got a question for you j-dub would you
consider the outer worlds a quality game
yes it's a quality game so what I'm
saying is do we not expect that from the
circle your own words said this
Microsoft didn't do that these guys had
this game but everyone keeps going with
the narrative that they're letting the
studios walk what they wanted Rockwood
so we gonna act like because they had in
the quality of the games they make it or
what they want but here's the thing
right here's the thing if all of these
Studios want to continue making the
small projects that they've been making
just it's not about what's been small on
the projects of the major these studios
that have been making these games they
were underfunded they had to be on
Kickstarter stay it's not like it's not
the same scenarios right it's not we can
keep in some EU magic theory said they
had to split their team up into
sometimes three or four teams just to
keep the doors open
listen you make out and they got the
check and then when they again listen
again it's that thing where wait we it
will come but but I remember cuz I
listen y'all know I recognize right 3
2014 field has been seen the greatest
games lineup in his tribe they do too
much on that but at the end of the day
their PR team they sell events that's
what literally a marketing team does
sure they might go a little extra but
literally that's what their job is to
get you excited again again what I do
when giving a company a person just
being realistic the ring doesn't off
again I'm being realistic
I finally aim for the conclusion right
apart my own personal opinion right that
I've waited this whole generation for
something that never came so think about
this Microsoft Xbox is a whole different
division then it was back in 2013 in
2013
they are in a better position to do what
they're doing now for bringing out they
are they are but I still have their
mindset in 2013-2014 go for the gusto be
number one go out there in Bangor for
Bangor in SME big guns they had you know
it's like I said we have to be realistic
and what would rob of reality the
world's most powerful cause all right
they showed that wealth we made Bob by
world forest company need to know the
world's poorest company and yet they're
knocking it out the park with their big
names with their middle games and their
small games in there is like oh we got
to be in the room reality realistic here
they their biggest bullets that they
could shoot they're not gonna shoot you
they announced next do you know how Sony
sold you own PS 5 before the night with
a five six seven dollar console and
being try to sell it you sell it based
on what you did the reason the reason
that the X came out was to take the
power a narrative away from Sony they
will tell me the power narrative didn't
switch you don't see the the powers of X
Red Dead look completed 2x ready
how many nothing's changed to be honest
with you we really gotta start wrapping
we going on it's a lot of intense to me
and if some good points on both sides I
hear where Attica King is saying you
know I'm saying in reference to the
timeframe and reference being realistic
in terms of what case or anything like
that it's a lot of Xbox fans just being
realistic
right now it's like
on a studio that was just acquired I can
you can't realistically ask us a company
like Microsoft to shoot their biggest
bullets before next I just have the same
energy with Google stadia to Crate OSes
point and this is the point and this is
a point that I've also been saying which
is that again we know this generation is
lost for Xbox there's no denying it
right we also know that Phil is
obviously trying to best turn around you
see the studio exist you see that the
future I agree with Ken the future in my
opinion doesn't look bright right I
really got a sinking ship yeah
absolutely absolutely the whole thing is
this now for people who are like cradles
or people who are Sony Playstation only
gamers right there is something to be
said about having shows even though this
is that e3 at it this is EXO 19 but
there is something about getting people
hype for the next generation to start
turning them all right so to do
something right so to crate OSes point
right like this fence right and EXO
whatever I bet it's like my point again
no disrespect to cartoon games right
they have a place I love Indies I love
switch yeah no Dex which gang all that
but people want to see stuff that
utilizes the power right people want to
see those oh my god moments right and
this is the only thing that I felt I
just gonna get it to my point now cuz
we've been crazy long my point with this
is I thought the show was solid was
probably the best inside Xbox one ain't
saying much but I thought the show us
out for the moment there was a lot of
fake jokes
right Kutner the timing was good it was
a little crazy but not as bad but the
whole thing is mostly these games
I got it meant y'all were not for me
right I'm not gonna say they're gonna be
bad I'm not gonna kiss right slit in in
the RTS they write that death won't
serve the only thing I would have liked
again maybe I'm asking for too much but
I see Nintendo do I see Sony do it is
now to me the show start off no shaky
then you know cuz we sorted the passion
projects from both you know obsidian and
whatever then it got in the middle I
thought s cloud was super strong right I
thought they dominated it got stadia out
it that's just my opinion right then the
game past announcement super strong gave
them the the whole idea that your game
passes around it ain't gonna be fought
oh we got the Final Fantasies we got the
Yakuza's we gave in the Japanese games
that we never known look nerd yeah we go
overlooked that Phil is definitely
making the presidency I'm not gonna do
it not only did he put games that's
never been on the platform he put them
in game past to give the game every
entry showing game pass is here to stay
I get that now you're starting and
strong you're showing more stuff right
Phil comes out now this is just me at
that moment I felt that's why I went
down here I don't know not any way down
I just felt it was a missed opportunity
because no disrespect to wasteland 3
like we said on the joint that could
have been shown everything in the middle
of the show this is well actually says
they were gonna open up with and they
ended with it so this is where I'm with
j-dub in the sense of this at that
moment they needed solve that yo one
more thing right and you just people yes
you so this is what again but they could
have showed something right this is what
the Nintendo fans in the Sony they get
they understand the theatrics of the
moment opens and wait the show was so if
they would have had that trust me the
narrative change we could the base like
oh my god this getting but I can't
believe it's actually coming even if
they just say your playgrounds working
on it you know 2021 not even released
they just show address again you got us
yes that's the only thing that's missing
in the that blows my mind is or ease at
the game award it's like like it would
have been I would have preferred them to
end the deed the show with or before
playing and that would have been a bad
but how many times of this show Tori oh
you're right wasteland is this and I get
what you guys are saying one of the most
like niche audiences you can have no no
no I'm not saying that um I'm not
justifying I'm ending the show with that
I understand them putting that in a
light you know because people stay there
and they captivated the audience after
wasteland he could have said but wait a
second hold on one second because when
he did the theatrics on stage and he
because it made it seem like a funky
thing you know um
they showed wasteland with updated
graphics they told you what the infusion
of the Microsoft cash did as far as the
dialog goes along with the game and you
can see the upgrades
alright that's that's fine and dandy
we're gonna get that game we're gonna
play that game if you have effect if you
have game pass you're going to play
these games like you can go play Rage 2
right now and other games like that
dissing game pass right now so you don't
have to starve yes
what the fact of the matter is I feel J
does when he said I want theatrics yes I
want to be I want to be told to sit down
in the corner and wait I want to be told
yo listen we got this coming our fable
y'all can look at this screen saver for
the next five years while we make it
because this is what he's used to with
Sony we will show you a little
screensaver
Nintendo will show you your screensaver
and you will say on a waiting room but
it works for certain people but don't
work for me I want to play rage too now
all right but here's the thing keep
ahold okay okay I gotta ask you this
though I hear what you say you want them
now you and we've had this argument
right tangible release dates versus hype
right yeah not be the first admit I'm
fraud it was a lot of times I used to
get mad with Sony with dope things out
too early then we like you know whatever
happened is such a such game but we have
to admit that it does allow what I'm
good all right yeah no doubt no doubt
they do what happens with your right but
I think you have to it does allow what I
call like good credit with your
community right like it gives you allows
them to be like oh we know this is still
coming in the back no say it allows
morley because let's be real like the
last two shows or III didn't show up but
you don't say they were kind of
recycling the same things over and over
there they showed good stuff about rice
game all I'm saying there is something
about emotional credit that you can give
your family just for the hardcore right
just say yo it's just this little thing
working on it next year when Sony brings
their behind the e3 mm-hmm I made
they're actually on stage and that's
showing those games that they're gonna
tear the stage down with cuz they're
gonna tear they're gonna I have full
expectations and high hopes that Sony's
gonna come within next-generation
gameplay and their stuff ready to rock
me uh let me ten and Microsoft needs to
make sure that they have their stuff
early in the basketball they will not
show fable screen cap or theater because
Phil isn't confident hits fan of just
learned from j-dub the the best I do
want to point out something like that I
don't think this isn't about confidence
because he's show engaged from rare that
stake claims not coming out to 2023 what
it is they got certain games they're
like I don't care what happens these are
not being showed to next-gen to be in
the round and one of the things that I'm
annoyed about is look they should have
looked at it cuz I know people will be
height for an educated people will be
height for fable and people will be high
for obsidians you know the game that
they really bought those studios for
they should have went to the table like
we're gonna we're gonna say one of those
for e3 and we're gonna show one of them
at excel and you know I get that they're
saving all this stuff for e3 but if they
would've just been like if at the end it
just showed a trailer right for the next
for the next digit theory if the the
whole thing would have been said let me
let me ask you and when you don't have
when you don't see here's the thing
right and it's a big difference between
the position at Sony's in in the
position Microsoft in like only has the
mind share in in that mind in this
industry my share goes with your mind
share can change in a blink of an eye it
can but right now I'm gonna now it's but
it can check yes but right now that that
my share is with with Sony
so Stoney can afford because obviously
look is working for him right tonight
show up at this scene I don't think it's
working for them they're getting
attacked at every corner for this listen
mister you saying they're getting attack
right but they'll come out every single
week every single month say look we
didn't soul such a such a game billion
games such as populate I get it we
didn't so 78% of the copies of the outer
worlds which is our competitions game we
we got all these V Ark and we still got
four or five bangers we got neo to
coming we got hosted Tsushima The Last
of Us
we got my we have guess what they've
been talking about PS five and letting
they're letting a little snippets out
about a bright horizon zero dawn to
write about the great about always
thinks they have the mind share by just
tweeting out in Microsoft don't have
that they need they don't have the
Liberty the thing is if Microsoft does
the other than my chair they they've
been hit so hard this generation they
can't afford to use all of their shots
before the next joke phones Nintendo had
the Wii U themselves you can't use that
excuse their Microsoft on the bottom
it's just reality let me tell you the
reality the reality is the Wii U all
with competing this generation it failed
Authority got back up dusted himself off
all jump on a horse he came back and
stole the money let me get this into
cradles to attics point mass generation
means don't harsher back all right hit
by Hitler here's the day in defense to a
dick cradles I gotta give him this with
the Nintendo example right the Wii U was
a I mean from afar failure right
it was L they weren't they weren't
showing us yo this is what we will be
doing with their guns for next week
that's gin that's what I saw in that
they did that always been the same
listen when Sony came out she was a
traitor what I'm saying is like okay and
I get it everybody has a bad generation
everybody
all's I get that ring but these
companies these other companies have
came back in in Rio right they came back
in that same generation Microsoft
instead of them going back every up they
said we're gonna change the whole game
we're just gonna do they didn't you know
they move the whole the whole arena and
I definitely understand look what I want
to point out to the chat is cradles
isn't wrong but my argument is I'm not
wrong either right from the perspective
of being a Sony fan what I'm saying
I'm coming from the behalf of a gamer
right in a gamer dad I couldn't all
right you're wrong not right but I did I
do not know don't don't get me wrong and
all I want Microsoft in Xbox to succeed
right
I wore the bangers I want them to cracks
we do got a a reimagine scalebound
coming back from the dance I don't want
their skill did you play that game he's
got it did a panel a large audience that
was Microsoft you can play it but
graphically began with what we're
looking for right now
right it was a realistic B I do not
whether the game would have turned out
to be crap or not but most games when
they come out right mmm they're not like
look at uncharted it came out try the
one came out everybody brushed over it
it was only until they reach up to a
part two and got a say they redid that
game catch fire and became is this
everybody's asking for these type of
games these realistic graphical type of
games right in the get it being it
people to say well Microsoft don't
really have those realistic type okay so
so what you're talking about like you
know that they're having stuff but you
ain't not get you you like you're saying
look like I know obsidian is making
multiple projects I know
Neji theories making multiple projects
but it's how I see that they're going
away from the stuff they're shown me now
I can't justify being high for now you
pay the bills real quick but Dallas team
Philo super chat showing games like
fable early takes the focus away from
smaller games just like the bangers have
affected two smaller games on ps4
bangers baby all games or you can so
large it is halo proof I do think the
reason they're not shown games like
fables cuz they want to connect that to
the next-gen console deigned a they want
them boat being written about at the
same time but but how is that gonna go
to work right we feel already saying no
man left behind so it doesn't matter
they they haven't said that lawyers if
you don't matter what's his name the
company was anything they was going away
from that he's gonna look good thing
what's gonna go that's how all games are
crossed Jim oh what I'm saying is right
he's saying focus on the next generation
which is Scarlett but I'm saying being
Xbox on Xbox we have Jill Sprint's had
already said no man left behind so if
you have my OG xbox to this day or but
said that years you know they're still
saying it the console generation is
going with would people would that
they're talking they're talking about
from an aspect of like accessories and
stuff they have not said that call
we'll carry on over generations anymore
years are going to go with you that Dave
Dave's no no he's talking about no
consoles could be left behind okay so
when we get to the next-gen you know all
this stuff's still gonna work on your OG
xbox will do that's what they're that's
the way they've been important one was
let's come here that it's been here's
backbone right now but they haven't they
haven't stressed that in years look how
much a flip-flop you look how much
Microsoft's flip-flopping this adds up
to you guys if he'll space or not say I
hate every street fighter I'll make that
up to you
did he not say that do you feel not safe
anymore
did the guy do something he says
everything everything that he says I'm
holding them to it right so always all
these Japanese RPGs you got it bang
that's it stop talking about it in there
now yeah gotcha OH
what was that with the Kingdom Hearts
you got that boom burning that's it
listen man
y'all gotta let the guy make his deals
you're not gonna sit there and act like
this stuff hasn't been changed and fixed
I feel you when you say I want bangers
give me bangers when you want it but you
won't have to wait til they get cooked
right just a single last of us to is
coming out this day and they said nah
hold on fam it's coming out later and
you should hate that biscuit you won't
eat this biscuit we saw the glazing on
the biscuit wait wait two months to be
able to guess what we can because we see
it waiting five years actual question
yes it only comes out tomorrow and say
you know what my bad
it was Marcus oh let him take care of
that you had a good show the show was a
good show
alright was it the shoulder everybody
wanted to know is a lot of times other
shows are done and it's not a show for
me right I told my way from a end up in
the same position saying exact same
thing neato like we showed did we say
the same thing about some easy three and
it was the same thing and we was that we
keep how many times have I said III salt
when the state of play first pumped out
people's like was any good well if you
like VR it was good it just wasn't for
me
that is true yeah look super Jan what
about when getting blown out put your
bed bench players in the game to work on
their fundamentals save your starters
for the next game better equals 20 20
look we got a minutes cuz we going crazy
ones like three hours in crazy listen I
I hear both sides
I hear both sides and one side is saying
yo be realistic allow these things to
cook it's just not how the industry
works and we have to be realistic the
other side is like yo fam I'm tired of
waiting the other side is doing over
here we cook it over here to basically I
feel that okay
so it's basically what it comes down to
is if you're going to wait for Microsoft
aka Kratos is wrong an annex right sort
of that at the end of the day I will say
this that with III right they need to
show out because at that point right but
at that we don't say it ever you but at
that point is there's no more excuses
right there's no more what else are we
gonna wait for will will will say wait
no I think this year because the costs
are watching it they don't watch
anything I had my doubts fables even in
production yes yes like have you saved
this right now this III is the last III
I give them if they don't do nothing
this III I'm gonna be on the j-dub Jacob
come out with anything this III I will
sign the pony contract look this III is
going to be such a stellar hit for both
consoles for the simple fact they got a
crush these stadia dudes and like you
said long money is your money so if
these do get these stuff together if
they if they regroup fast yeah you know
it is gonna be at a detriment to to
console gamer so the true III is this
III and I want to see both of those guys
representing because not for nothing
last year last
III it was a boy that was there and I'm
used to seeing Sony with their theatrics
they should have at least been on the
floor for their fans
there's no did yeah I believe they're
gonna be there and they need to be there
remember some who had that money at
Microsoft have so Dave scraped a little
penis together in try to you know try to
postpone it whether it works for and
we'll see we'll see everyone here that
watch XO well what you do is I want you
to put and filled ominous if it was a
good show or into the bushes it was bad
all right Joe
let's get the polls get out here with
the majority of the major release is now
being shipped in 2019 what is your
current choice for game of the
the choices are a b c d e when he goes
on lord crate so sticking with us in o t
mad spoke he was now playing today boy
the show without a doubt boy same thing
and i wake up and i'm breathing
we will i will be at e3 and i will be
epic
look he's gonna be their life so they
don't do this literally you know my
little pony pony backpack you gotta pull
up man we definitely hear the Lord's
will be a treat will be great to see
have some jokes and laugh again at the
end again is the evening of a lifetime
this relax any previous III ever the
duration foot for the twig foot 2020s
bob's golly this is we in the in game
right here yes always a pleasure to have
you this is a wild show this year breezy
Lords of the realm Lord addict extending
the time when telling me to speed up the
time go against you o T what's going
over looking above upon G I'll pee where
I'll be announcing my victory over
Kratos
you can find me on uh on YouTube gaming
add a first I want to appreciate
everyone for coming out I know the chat
was led to super Chester's late now more
really really wants you know express
that you know it's nice that so many
people supported the members we put a
lot of time into that it's nice to see
that came into good out but I want it
you know I seen a lot of you at my
personal channel too and I want to thank
every witch on you that comes over there
I want to thank crate us or j-dub aka
County Commissioner because it should be
but you know I know this man has always
been a supporter and it's not he's kind
of the person that that that's on
Twitter so you can find me on Twitter
lowest IOP PSN xbox live big shout out
to create like Kratos comes in he knows
[Music]
every time I hope that people who listen
to our show who only have like troll
Kratos on Twitter realize what a
well-rounded game you are and personal
he really doesn't get that Stadium
home he was not overly for how much he
plays games you know how much supportive
he is to the community he is the biggest
troll on Twitter that is literally my
fellow ponies to take me out made me I
got I got it I got it I got it I got
ahold of line man and of course Lord keg
super spoke today was crazy I can't keep
up a shot so listen now first and
foremost I'm thankful that cradles came
in after I put that Janet Jackson Mimi
like this this is my guy over here and I
swear to tell you guys when I when I
tell y'all like he plays on everything
I'm only saying that because I'm want
Xbox dudes they feel like oh I got a go
at this dude ya know in the same way
that you like whatever you game on but
you have other things as well you have
other interests this man told you yeah I
got stadia you know alright don't have
idiot wrapping wrapping right so you
gotta give this man his respect when he
when he when he comes through here he's
trolling he's joking but he also gives
out consoles he's also he helped a lot
of dudes out and y'all gotta understand
that he's a very good dude and anytime
I'm joking when I'm just joking but you
can catch me at Kos you can catch me at
log net there's loads of gaming dotnet
you can catch me on a Lords podcast and
you catch me on Twitter at King David
OTW see that statue in the background
you see that halt little catch they said
bad cosplay guys are cosplay and we're
doing different things that we're
bringing stuff to the community we
yeah pleased and happy that it was well
received with the joining of the members
today um if you look down at the screen
you can see a join button click on that
see what it is it's a 99 for bronze it's
$7.99 for silver and it's $14.99 for
gold the different perks involved if you
saw different emojis that was inside the
chat today those emojis is afforded to
you when you become a member
else you can go to the teespring store
once you become a member and you get a
discount automatically a 5% of the
silver and 10% on the gold so you guys
without you guys none of this move
forward also would love to give another
birthday shout-out to lower kognito um
this man does so much and he works so
hard when you go to Lord met and you see
the statues and you see the synapses
LOCOG needle put that together alright
and um he does that
after doing crunches all week on other
things and he's still finding time to
help out you know this Lord over here so
I truly appreciate him and I don't think
he gets enough credit you know for
holding this together cuz this could've
really went off the rails today I do
I got to point out something I do think
we missed a super chair yes before we
don't know did you decided by the truth
did we get that there was a $2 super
chair from game over HD gaming Atticus
blinded by the truth you know what your
honestly because we missed it so agree
with you guys that we missed that yeah
so soft on that juice today he got that
kudzu with good stuff Thank You King
much appreciated but yeah fire show
today was insane again with much much
love from everybody in the chat just
showing craziness with the subscription
and the memberships really appreciated
we see them emojis moving out of here
that that's crazy man I love shouted
j-dub of course my brother you already
know we do you know sense so that was
fun and yeah like I said please support
loss of gaming dotnet
fire article
or up and that's pretty much Rick Trudy
we got some popping over oh yeah you're
gonna see this is gonna be one of your
first behind-the-scenes views
there'll be posting videos up for the
members that are there to get a lot of
these shows that we were at with that
ugly see we got those pills is doing up
here we also have our packs and we have
more III videos that have stuff that you
have not seen before which are privy to
and y'all will see it and you can
peeling this and of course next week
should be a nice treat we'll have a
special industry dress so stay tuned for
that will reveal that later but I'm like
King said man again
really look out for us we got a lot of
things going on that's all I got at it
you got anything else cuz you want to
keep show going off for hours
okay okay all right everybody we out of
here please